Hallo und herzlich willkommen zu UKW, unsere kleine Welt. Mein Name ist Tim Prittlaff und ich begrüße alle zur 108. Ausgabe von UKW.
Und heute soll es nach zwei Monaten Pause dann doch mal wieder um den Konflikt in der Ukraine, den Krieg in der Ukraine gehen.
Dazu begrüße ich selbstverständlich wieder Pawel. Hallo, Pawel.
Hallo Tim.
Genau und es ist nun einige Zeit vergangen. Wir hatten zwischendurch immer mal wieder so ein bisschen dieses Gefühl, so eigentlich müsste man langsam mal wieder was zusammenfassen, aber ist eigentlich irgendwas wirklich passiert? Also es ist natürlich eine Menge passiert, weil es passiert da jeden Tag eine ganze Menge.
Allerdings an den großen elementaren Änderungen, die wir dann zuletzt verkündet haben, nämlich zum Stand des 16. November, haben wir darüber gesprochen, wie die Cherson-Offensive,
der Ukraine erfolgreich war und die Russen über den Dnieper zurückgedrängt wurden. wurden. Das war natürlich dann so die letzte große tektonische Verschiebung, aber seitdem.
Hat sich eigentlich alles im Wesentlichen dort, hält sich alles im Wesentlichen dort auf, wo wir es dann zuletzt vorgefunden haben. Vielleicht zu Beginn einen kleinen Überblick,
worüber wir sprechen wollen. Also zunächst einmal denke ich, ist es ganz sinnvoll, grob.
Diese militärische Lage zu beschreiben.
Dann gehen wir nochmal spezifisch auf einige Schwerpunktthemen der letzten zwei Monate im Krieg ein.
Da ist natürlich zunächst einmal der Krieg auf die ukrainische, also der Angriff auf die ukrainische Infrastruktur zu nennen, den man im Prinzip ja schon seit einem Jahr hat. Aber es wurde ja dann eben nochmal spezifisch konkret auf die Energieinfrastruktur.
Haben sich die Russen darauf konzentriert und das hatte entsprechende Auswirkungen.
Die Ukraine hat auch zurückgeschlagen. Wir gucken nochmal auf die wieder speziellen Antworten, die Ukraine in diesem Krieg militärisch hat geben können, speziell diese Drohnenangriffe auf die russischen Airbases.
Ja und dann müssen wir einfach ganz viel über Militärtechnik reden, weil das war natürlich dann auch so das politische Hauptthema der letzten zwei Monate gewesen. Schon nach der
Energieinfrastruktur-Diskussion ging das los und hat jetzt jüngst seine Eskalation gehabt,
in der Frage um diese Main Battle Tanks, um die Kampfpanzer und dann eben speziell um die Leopard 2 Panzer. Genau, dann wollen wir mal darüber diskutieren, was das eigentlich jetzt so für Folgen haben könnte. Zum Abschluss blicken wir dann nochmal so auf die Situation.
In Russland und was wir denken, wie so der Krieg seinen weiteren Verlauf nehmen könnte und was man vielleicht auch generell so für politische Fazite bisher draus ziehen kann,
jetzt wo wir fast beim einjährigen Jubiläum angekommen sind. Jubiläum ist ein bisschen.
Falsch das Wort in dem Zusammenhang, da gibt es nicht so viel zu jubeln, aber ja, der 24. Februar wird sicherlich dann ohnehin in der Öffentlichkeit noch mal ein Moment der Reflektion sein, aber wir wollen jetzt mal vorher schon ein bisschen reflektieren, was eigentlich so passiert ist.
Ja fangen wir doch mal an wie schon angekündigt mit der militärischen Lage.
Also vielleicht erst mal direkt anknüpfend an das, was zuletzt passiert war, als wir die letzte Sendung gemacht haben, also dieser Übernahme der Stadt Creson und damit eben auch die Übernahme des nördlichen Teils des Landes Creson, des Bundeslandes Creson, des Oblast Creson, der ja eben durch diesen Dnieperov-Fluss geteilt ist.
Und die Russen sind seitdem eben südlich, oder wie man es betrachten möchte, östlich des Flusses verbarrikadiert, während die Ukraine halt im Norden komplett, bzw. dann im Westen, komplett die Kontrolle übernommen hat.
Am Anfang war es dann erst mal ruhig. man merkt, Russland muss dann erst mal sich sammeln, aber seitdem geht es halt so weiter, wie man das schon hat kommen sehen. Das heißt, die Stadt Kreson, die ist natürlich jetzt
nicht so weit weg von den russischen Stellungen, die wird am laufenden Meter weiter bombardiert, so wie man das von den anderen Städten auch schon kennt. Was man nicht haben kann, das
macht man eben kaputt. Das ist ein Problem und die Ukrainer versuchen halt an der Stelle mit Spezialmaßnahmen in irgendeiner Form dieser Situation herzuwerden.
Spezialmaßnahmen heißt auf der einen Seite so Reconnaissance-Maßnahmen. Das heißt, es sind wahrscheinlich immer mal wieder Spezialtruppen in diesem Gebiet im Einsatz, um dort Aufklärung zu betreiben und dann in Zusammenarbeit,
vielleicht eben auch mit entsprechenden Kollaboratoren oder beziehungsweise in dem Fall sind das keine Kollaborateure, sondern ich suche das Wort, Leute, die.
Partisan.
Halt da Partizan, das war es, was ich gesucht habe, richtig. Also Leute, die da aktiv im Widerstand sind und dann eben Informationen liefern über Truppenkonzentrationen. Und das wurde mehr
als nur einmal genutzt, um dann eben mit diesen hochpräzisen High-Mars-Raketensystemen oder es sind GLMRS-Raketensystemen, dann solche Truppen- oder Munitionskonzentrationen zu zerstören. Das.
Schwächt natürlich die Russen und grundsätzlich kann man sagen, dass derzeit es so aussieht, als ob der Artilleriebeschuss insgesamt ein wenig zurückgegangen ist, aber das kann auch nur so eine Momentaufnahme sein. Offensichtlich will man jetzt erstmal Munition sparen, ob das.
Dann eben bedeutet, dass man generell einen Versorgungsengpass hat oder ob man sich sozusagen nur kurz mal wieder sammelt und aufstaut, um dann noch härter zuschlagen zu können, das weiß man dann meistens immer erst danach. Auf jeden Fall ist diese ganze Situation dort noch sehr offen.
Es gab verschiedenste Berichte, dass es den Ukrainern gelungen sein soll, hier und da über den Fluss zu treten. Aber das waren wahrscheinlich alles nur solche Aufklärungsmissionen und es gibt.
Da gibt es keine wirklich großen, nennenswerten militärischen Bewegungen in diesem ganzen Gebiet.
Es gab Bilder von einer Sabotage-Mission, wo dann Special Ops über den Fluss sind und dann eine russische Stellung gesprengt haben.
Ja, so was, das ist ja das, was ich meinte. Also mit solchen Special Forces, das findet am laufenden Meter statt, aber das sind natürlich nur so Nadelstiche. Klar, hier und da wird dann halt mal was, aber damit ist jetzt kein Vormarsch groß erreicht.
Also sie haben es geschafft, die Russen zumindest unmittelbar vom Ufer wegzudrängen, weil sie dann natürlich zu nah in der ganz gut funktionierenden ukrainischen.
Artilleriezone sind, aber immer noch nah genug, um halt Schaden anzurichten.
Ja, das heißt, im Wesentlichen ist die ganze Kriegsaktivität der letzten zwei Monate, die hat sich im Osten abgespielt und da gibt es verschiedene
Konzentrationsorte, wo sich alles besonders zeigt und wo sich die Russen sozusagen darauf konzentriert haben. Die haben sich also dieser Bürde von Resson entledigt und werfen jetzt alles an die Front, was sie haben, um in
irgendeiner Form irgendwelche Fortschritte zu machen. Man kann schon mal sagen, es gab zwar welche, aber keine nennenswerten. Das heißt, im Großen und und Ganzen ist es ein Stellungskrieg. Es gibt Gebiete, wo die Ukrainer ein bisschen Boden gut gemacht haben. Das ändert sich dann aber auch teilweise täglich und wöchentlich.
Es gibt Gebiete, wo die Russen etwas Boden gut gemacht haben, teilweise unter extrem großen Verlusten. Aber so im Großen und Ganzen ist halt eigentlich alles sehr statisch,
und das hat verschiedene Gründe. Einer der Gründe ist natürlich Mangel an Gerät, Mangel an Munition auf Seiten der Ukrainer bzw. ein Mangel an Versorgung auf der russischen Seite.
Aber es hat auch was damit zu tun, die letzte Sendung hieß ja Winter is coming bei uns.
Und tja, ist aber nicht so richtig gekommen. Also es gab bisher keine wirklich ausgedehnten Frostperioden, auf die man eigentlich immer gewartet hat.
Der Boden in der Ukraine ist in dieser Jahreszeit, wenn er nicht gefroren ist, extrem matschig und schwer zu befahren. Das ermöglicht es also nicht mit schwerem Gerät, sich schnell irgendwo rein zu bewegen.
Und aus dem ganzen Krieg ist im Wesentlichen ein Infanteriekrieg geworden.
Das gilt speziell für die Russen, die einfach sehr viel mehr auf Infanteriegruppen setzen, einfach Wellen von Leuten einfach nach vorne schicken als Kanonenfutter,
so lange bis sich irgendwas verbessert hat und man kann leider auch sagen, dass das nicht ohne Erfolg war.
Ja, es ist ein bisschen raffinierter, was sie halt getan haben dort, speziell in der Bachmuth-Solidar-Region, ist, dass sie halt die, ja, im Wesentlichen die Sträflinge und.
Qualifizierte Truppen als Kanonenfutter, wenn man so will, als erstes nach vorne geschickt haben, was dann natürlich ukrainisches Feuer auf sich gezogen hat, woraufhin dann die,
ich sag mal qualifizierteren Truppen in zweiter Reihe dann geguckt haben, wo denn die ukrainischen
Stellungen sind und die dann unter Feuer genommen haben.
Das war quasi das Ding, das hat einerseits eben diesen großen Verlusten geführt, auf
der anderen Seite eben auch dann ist den Russen ermöglicht, wiederum ukrainische Stellungen unter Feuer zu nehmen.
Genau, und das vor allem halt mit Mörsergruppen, also viel Infanterie unterwegs. Mörser haben halt dafür den Vorteil, dass man die eben sehr viel leichter bewegen kann,
weil das einfach so relativ kleine Geräte sind, aber das können die Russen wohl ganz gut.
Und setzen die massenhaft ein und das hat dann eben diese Strategie auch unterstützt.
Genau, ich würde mal ganz gerne diese Hauptkampforte, das sind im Wesentlichen so vier Gebiete auf denen sich das alles abgespielt hat, wo sich mehr oder weniger überall dasselbe Bild ergibt.
Aber die vielleicht mal aufzählen. Ihr könnt das ja mal auf einer Karte vielleicht nachvollziehen. Die ganze Frontlinie zieht sich ja dann im Osten, also von Rakiv so nach Süden runter und macht dann halt nach links irgendwann nach Donetsk so einen Knick Richtung Saporizhja und dann Cherson.
Saporizhia, Kreson werde ich jetzt gar nicht groß ins Auge fassen. Es gab zwar
überall irgendwelche einzelnen Gefechte und Vorstöße, aber so diese großen vier Bereiche, die spielen sich halt dann an dieser gesamten Ostfront und dann hinter diesem ersten Knick ab. Also alles relativ nah auch beieinander. Also.
Relativ nah. Handelt sich hier natürlich immer noch mehrere hundert Kilometer.
Also los geht's erstmal in Swatowe und Kriminal auf dieser Achse. Das ist im Prinzip jetzt nach wie vor die nächste Frontlinie, die sich nach dem Vorstoß,
der Ukraine ergeben hat, als sie diese riesigen Gebiete in Kharkiv.
Eingenommen haben. Also diese große Landnahme noch bevor die Russen Kreson aufgeben mussten, die ja super erfolgreich war und wo die Russen komplett auf dem linken Fuß erwischt wurden, weil sie einfach die Gebiete nicht ausreichend abgesichert haben.
Die Ukraine das gemerkt hat und dann sehr schnell vorgestoßen ist und dabei eben große Gebiete wieder zurückerobert hat.
Und am Ende hat sich aber dann eben so eine Frontlinie ergeben, die eben dann auf dieser Nord-Süd-Achse zwischen den Orten Svatové und Kreminar sich abbildet.
Und das war halt jetzt wirklich ein extremes Hin und Her. Hier hat die Ukraine im Wesentlichen Schritte nach vorne gemacht, aber irgendwo war dann halt einfach Schluss, weil eben, wie schon erwähnt, die Russen einfach das mit Personalfolge,
ballert haben.
Einfach ihre ganzen Mobilisierten da rein gehauen.
Ja und hinzu kam, dass dann sie bis an einen Punkt gekommen sind, wo einfach das Gelände und die Geografie den Verteidiger bevorzugt. Also in dem Fall ein mehr geschlossenes Gebiet, wo man nicht so gut dann mit Panzern durchkommt,
sondern nur um.
Plus halt weicher Boden, kleine Waldstücke etc. Also ein enormer taktischer Stellungskrieg, der sich da abgespielt hat.
In dieser Region würde ich aber sagen, hat Ukraine so ein bisschen die Nase vorn, aber es kam halt nicht wirklich zu einem weiteren großen Erfolg nach der Einnahme von Lyman.
Das mag auch mit der Verfügbarkeit von Waffen zu tun haben, lässt sich schwer sagen.
Sollte es gelingen, in einem März-April-Vorstoß, über den gemunkelt wird, auch hier Fortschritte zu erzielen. Die Einnahme von Swatowe und insbesondere
die Einnahme von Kriminar wäre ein großer Erfolg, weil das so eine ganz wichtige Halteachse ist für die Russen und Kriminar ist dann halt auch so ein bisschen das Tor in diesen eigentlichen industriellen Donbass-Bereich, also die Städte Lusitcansk und Sierwero do Netsk.
Wenn er uns vom halben Jahr, das war so der Ort wo da am meisten gekämpft wurde, wo die Russen alles draufgehauen haben,
sollten die Russen das wieder verlieren, das wäre für die schon ein ein sehr
großer Verlust, aber davon sind wir derzeit noch weit entfernt. Der zweite wesentliche Kampfbereich ist halt die Region über
Umbach, Mut und Solidar, das ist ja schon fast so der nächste, wie soll man sagen, ich hab fast Heiliger Krieg gesagt, also so ein Symbolkrieg und.
Zwar sowohl für die Russen, weil sie in irgendeiner Form nach Erfolgen lächzen und solche halt eigentlich im letzten halben Jahr nicht wirklich vorzuweisen haben. Und Bachmuth ist dann halt auch
so die Stadt, die sich diese Wagner-Truppen besonders vorgenommen haben. Wagner, diese private Armee,
die es so offiziell ja eigentlich gar nicht geben darf, aber halt trotzdem gibt, also in Russland spielen jetzt legale Gründe eigentlich selten jetzt noch eine große Rolle, zumindest nicht was diesen Krieg betrifft. Auf jeden Fall sind die dort halt massiv stationiert und haben halt einfach einfach diese ganzen Leute, die sie aus dem Knast geholt haben, da an die Front geworfen.
Und noch ist es so, dass die Stadt Bachmuth gehalten werden kann, aber sie wird halt in zunehmendem Maße eingeschlossen.
Es gab jetzt hier gerade in den letzten zwei Wochen eine größere Niederlage für die Ukraine, nämlich in diesem Ort Sule-Dar, der lange Zeit gehalten werden konnte, weil er eigentlich
ideal geeignet war zum Verteidigen, weil es so eine Salzminenstadt war und da gab es halt viele entsprechende industrielle Gebäude und diese Salzminentunnel etc., die sie
wohl auch eingesetzt haben, um teilweise so hinter dem Feind hervorzukriechen und im Rücken anzugreifen. Trotzdem war es dann einfach irgendwann nicht mehr zu halten, weil die Russen weiter im Norden einen anderen Ort sich haben einheimsen können und in zunehmendem Maße von verschiedenen Seiten angriffen und.
Irgendwann ist dann einfach der Widerstand gebrochen.
Damit schält sich die Front so ein bisschen im Norden um Wachmutter rum.
Die haben einfach so sah es zumindest aus, einfach alles kurz und klein bombardiert. Von erobern kann fast gar nicht mehr die Rede sein von dem, was da dann übrig bleibt.
Das wird einfach platt gemacht.
Auf der anderen Seite haben die Ukrainer schon lange in den Stellungen geblieben, so, dass da es auch zu mehr Opfern gekommen ist, als die Ukraine normalerweise bereit sind.
So zu Opfern. Aber man merkte halt, man wollte es eben auch den Russen nicht leicht machen,
sondern irgendwie jeden für jeden Meter teuren Preis abnehmen. Aber das war halt
eben auch für die Ukraine nicht wirklich billig. Zu Wagner vielleicht nur noch so zwei kleine Hinweise. Das eine ist, dass ja die Serben jetzt einen ziemlichen
einen Ärger gemacht haben, weil da wohl ein paar Serben auch irgendwo bei Wagner bzw.
Auf russischer Seite gesehen wurden und Wagner dort auch Anzeigen geschaltet hatte und da
hat jetzt die serbische Regierung protestiert und das war ein ziemlicher Skandal, sag ich
mal, in Serbien, weil das halt illegal ist nach serbischem Gesetz, nach russischem auch,
wie du gesagt hattest. Ja, und gut, dann kommen wir vielleicht später noch drauf.
Was politisch gerade an Graben kämpfen läuft. Aber so viel, dass jetzt auch die russische
angefangen hat, Straftäter einzusetzen und jetzt Prigozhin so ein bisschen seine Versorgung.
Abgeschnitten hat. Also interessanterweise scheint die russische Armee auch teilweise dazu
übergegangen zu sein, so ein paar Wagner-Strategie-Taktiken wie auch immer zu kopieren.
Das ist vielleicht zu wacke an der Stelle.
Also wie lange die Ukraine Bachmut noch halten kann, ist derzeit sehr unklar. Es gibt halt sowohl den Erfolg im Norden als auch den Erfolg im Süden. Das heißt, dieses Umschließen der
Vielen Dank für's Zuschauen.
Stadt schreitet voran und dabei könnten halt wichtige Versorgungsstraßen wegfallen und irgendwann wird es dann auch schwierig. Also es ist sehr schwer einzuschätzen, da die Russen scheinen,
also hier wirklich ihren Hauptschwerpunkt drauf gelegt zu haben.
Am Ende, ich meine, wenn sie die Stadt einnehmen, dann ist es zwar schade, ja, und ist eine weitere Stadt, die erst mal wieder befreit werden muss. Nur.
Militärisch ist am Ende für die Russen hier nicht so sehr viel gewonnen, aber man muss halt auch sagen, das ist natürlich eine wichtige Frontstadt,
Denn die nächste Linie, die hier mit größeren Städten ausgestattet ist, das ist dann halt.
Diese Achse Slowiansk-Kramatorsk und Kramatorsk ist halt so das Widerstandszentrum überhaupt. Also das war schon immer so der Hauptstandort für die ukrainischen Truppen im Donbass.
Dort liegt quasi das Kommandozentrum, soweit ich das weiß. Das ist nicht schön und man will natürlich auch nicht, dass die Russen.
Hier im Donbass noch weiter vorankommen. Also hier stürzen sie sich sozusagen auf dieses restliche Gebiet, aber da ist noch sehr viel Gebiet, was sie im Donbass erobern müssten und die Fortschritte waren halt sehr teuer. Also das Tempo werden sie so nicht lange durchhalten können.
Dritter Ort und eigentlich auch immer so eine absurde Gesamtsituation eigentlich in diesem Krieg ist halt die Umgebung der großen Stadt Donetsk.
Es gibt ja immer so den Oblast Donetsk und es gibt dann halt auch die Stadt, die so heißt, wie das ja in Chersan auch ist und Saporizhja und überhaupt ist das sehr
verbreitet in der Ukraine, Rakiv genauso. Die Stadt Donetsk, da war ja die Frontlinie unmittelbar vor der Stadt und das ist ja auch immer noch. Und dort gibt es halt auch zwei Orte, wo die Russen die ganze Zeit drauf stürzen, sich drauf stürzen, drauf stürmen.
Aber hier ist eigentlich relativ wenig Bewegung. Also da gibt es kleinere Fortschritte, die Russen gemacht haben hier im letzten halben Jahr, aber die bewegen sich alle so im Bereich von ein.
Paar hundert Meter, vielleicht ein Kilometer, den sie hier und da mal vorangegangen sind. Also da kann kann man eigentlich nicht viel zu sagen.
Und so der letzte Ort, wo es in letzter Zeit größere Gefechte gegeben hat, das ist die kleine Stadt Wuledar, beziehungsweise im Süden davon die Stadt.
Pavlivka. Die Russen haben irgendwie monatelang auf Pavlivka eingerannt und haben dort auch extrem hohe Verluste gehabt. Mittlerweile haben
sie die Stadt eingenommen, aber ein bisschen weiter hoch den Berg ist halt Wuledar, da tobt jetzt gerade der Veit. Das ist gerade noch offen. Ob es den Russen jetzt hier
gelingt Wuledar einzunehmen, das wäre nicht gut für die Ukraine, weil das eigentlich ein ganz wichtiger Stronghold ist, denn im Prinzip sind alle davon ausgegangen, dass das so einer der Orte
ist, wo vielleicht die Ukraine auch eine neue Offensive startet. Also dass man von hier von Wuledar nach Süden geht, weil das im Prinzip so ein bisschen das Tor Richtung Mariopolis ist.
Also nicht um jetzt gleich die Stadt Mariopol einzunehmen, davon sind sie weit entfernt,
aber auch um die Eisenbahn-Straßenverbindungen dort komplett zu kappen und damit eben die Versorgung des Westens der besetzten Gebiete weiter einzuschränken. Muss man sehen. Also das.
Ist im Wesentlichen eigentlich die militärische Lage. Es geht viel vor und zurück. Die Russen mit einem extrem hohen Verbrauch an Menschen und Kriegsmaterial schaffen es hier und da
Durchbrüche zu feiern. Haben jetzt leider in den letzten paar Wochen etwas größere Fortschritte gemacht, die aber insgesamt nicht so dramatisch sind, dass man sagen.
Könnte, der Krieg hat eine Wende genommen. Was man aber sagen kann, ist, dass dieses Momentum der Ukrainer, die ja lange Zeit bestimmt waren, wo jetzt eigentlich der Krieg seine Dynamik entfaltet,
dass das jetzt aufgebraucht ist und dass das wieder zurück an die Russen gegangen ist.
Man kann definitiv konstatieren, dass das Momentum der Ukraine verloren gegangen ist und die Russen es geschafft haben, den Vormarsch der Ukraine zum Stillstand zu bringen und
jetzt eben selber, würde ich sagen, leicht in die Initiative zu gehen oder Initiative übernommen zu haben.
Aber es ist nicht klar, wie lange sie das halten können. Auf der anderen Seite haben sie sich auch extrem damit beschäftigt, sich tief einzugraben, also auch weit hinter den Frontlinien entsprechende Verteidigungslinien neu aufzubauen.
Da gilt sowohl der Südbereich von Creson, also im Vorfeld zu Krim.
Da ist das an vielen Stellen passiert.
Und dann gibt es auch noch diese merkwürdige sogenannte Wagner-Linie, die so den Namen gefunden hat.
Die ist doppelt absurd. Es handelt sich dabei um eine Befestigung tief im Luhansk herum, tatsächlich, im Donbass. Also nicht unbedingt jetzt da, wo gerade die Frontlinie ist, sondern
eben viele Kilometer weiter im besetzten Gebiet. Sozusagen als zusätzliche Absicherung. Und.
Diese Absicherung besteht aus einem über Kilometer lang gezogenen tiefen, ich glaube,
Doppelgraben, der dann auch noch mit diesen absurden Betonpyramiden bestückt ist, also um sozusagen ein einfaches Überfahren durch Panzer zu verhindern. Und noch absurder Weise,
gibt es so etwas auch auf russischem Gebiet. Also diese Wagner-Linie zieht sich teilweise auch in russisches gebiet rein wo schon alle sich ein bisschen am kopf gekratzt haben und sagten so gehen die jetzt wirklich davon aus dass dass dass dass.
Dass jemand sie auf ihrem eigenen Boden angreift.
Ja, ganz offensichtlich. Und so eine der letzten bis vielleicht ein bisschen mehr als Gerüchte ist, dass jetzt die russischen Militärangehörigen in Luhansk evakuiert worden sind nach Russland,
Sodass die Russen wohl davon ausgehen, dass die nächste große Offensive der Ukraine in
der Luhansk-Region kommt und sie dem wohl nicht sicher standhalten werden.
Das ist zumindest das Mindset der Russen im Moment. Plus gibt es Berichte über größere neue Truppenkonzentrationen in der Gegend von Luhansk,
... für ukrainische Truppenkonzentrationen.
Also das macht auf jeden Fall so den Eindruck, dass die Ukraine so ähnlich wie sie es schon mal im Sommer gemacht hat, so ein doppeltes Spiel macht.
Auf der einen Seite, man hält halt die Stellung, man gibt auch nicht so schnell auf bei in Gebieten, wo eigentlich der Druck extrem stark ist, also auch der Kampf um Sierwero Donetsk und Lüssi Csanks war ja auch sehr verlustreich für die Ukrainer.
Hat aber den Ukrainern halt viel Zeit gegeben.
Dann trafen die Heimars-Raketen ein und dann hat sich ja das Blatt das erste Mal gedreht so richtig. Das heißt, man musste erst mal diesem extremen Powerangriff durch.
Übermächtige Artillerie in irgendeiner Form etwas entgegenhalten. Jetzt haben wir vielleicht eine ähnliche Situation. Auf der einen Seite dürften sie.
Gehofft haben, dass sie einen sehr kalten Winter unter Umständen eine Gelegenheit haben, hier und da nochmal durchzubrechen. Sie haben vielleicht auch gehofft, schon über besseres Material zu verfügen. Thema.
Panzer, da werden wir gleich noch ausführlich drauf kommen. Das hat so, glaube ich, alles nicht stattgefunden. In der Zwischenzeit haben sie aber eben auch geschafft, neue Versorgungslinien zu
eröffnen, eigene Artillerieproduktion zu starten etc. Also es passiert halt im Hintergrund auch eine ganze Menge, was letzten Endes eine langfristige Auswirkung auf den Krieg haben soll.
Und ich denke, dass wir auch gerade so eine Phase erleben, wo die Ukraine erst mal versucht, so weit gegenzuhalten, dass sich nichts nennenswert verschlimmert und im Hintergrund sozusagen.
Alles neu aufzustellen, um dann weitere entscheidende Fortschritte zu erzielen.
Da gehen wir später nochmal ein bisschen detaillierter beim Ausblick.
Also das ist das sozusagen so in etwa das. So was man jetzt auch noch erwähnen muss, ist natürlich, was in der Zwischenzeit auch noch passiert ist.
Ist abgesehen der Frontkämpfe gab es natürlich auch die Angriffe auf die ukrainische Energieinfrastruktur.
Und das war sehr perfide, weil es natürlich dann voll auf die zivile Bevölkerung geht, in dem es in überhaupt gar keine militärischen Ziele hat.
Aber das ist ja jetzt an diesen Krieg, wenn man auf Russlands Methoden schaut, auch überhaupt nichts Neues, also so richtig überrascht hat es keinen. Aber es war natürlich extrem, weil sie wirklich immer solche Kampagnen geflogen haben
mit Cruise Missiles, mit billigen iranischen Drohnen, alles was irgendwie fliegt, dann diese KH, wie heißt die?
KH-101 Missiles von den Schiffen im Schwarzen Meer. Also sozusagen so eine
Mixtur aus Langstrecken, Raketen, Mittelstrecken, Raketen und Drohnen, die zwar auch weite Strecken schaffen, aber halt nicht so viel Explosionskraft haben.
Und haben die dann eben gezielt auf Energieinfrastruktur, sprich auf Stromverteilerstruktur, insbesondere so diese ganzen Unterverteiler,
Transformatoren, die so einfach irgendwo in der Botanik stehen und von denen es eben viele gibt, die aber auch sehr wichtig sind, um die Ukraine in der Lage ist,
das Netz weiter auszubalancieren und natürlich auch um den Strom weiter zu verteilen. Auf der einen Seite und auf der anderen Seite Heizkraftwerke.
Man wollte also einfach das Land ausbluten lassen, indem das Heizen nicht ermöglicht wird etc. Und natürlich ist auch ein Mangel an Strom auch nicht gut für ein Land,
was gerade im Krieg ist. Allerdings muss man sagen, also das war zwar dahingehend erfolgreich, dass das wirklich eine ganze Menge kaputt gegangen ist und je nachdem, welchen Bericht man so glauben darf, kann man davon ausgehen, dass so gut 50 Prozent der Energieinfrastruktur,
vielleicht 60 Prozent der Energieinfrastruktur Schaden genommen hat. Davon ist sicherlich noch nicht alles repariert worden, wenn auch viel wieder sehr schnell in Stand gesetzt werden
konnte, zumindest dahingehend, dass es eben überhaupt wieder in Betrieb war. Manches wurde ja dann auch bei Angriffen erst mal notabgeschaltet, damit es nicht unter Last getroffen wird und noch größere Konsequenzen hat als ohnehin schon. Das ist also sozusagen,
einmal so die logistische Antwort, die die Ukraine dort geliefert hat, aber es gab natürlich.
Dann auch eine internationale Reaktion, weil das war natürlich dann wieder so ein Punkt, wo sich dann die Welt mal wieder gewahr wurde, dass es sich ja dann doch bei so einem Krieg auch um eine humanitäre Katastrophe handelt und entsprechend wurden dann neue Flugabwehrsysteme bewilligt, die der Ukraine zukamen.
Es ist ja schon interessant, dass ausgerechnet dieser Gepard, ein Panzer, der bei der Bundeswehr bereits in der Verschrottung anstand, dass das eins der effizientesten Abwehrsysteme in der Ukraine ist.
Mittlerweile sind dort auch 36 Stück im Einsatz, das sind nicht nur ein paar Einzelsysteme mehr.
Die letzten sieben, die es noch gibt, die jetzt gerade noch repariert werden, die gehen jetzt irgendwie auch noch hin. Und drei, die eigentlich schon in der Verschrottungspipeline waren, die werden jetzt auch nochmal wieder entstand gesetzt.
Vielleicht sind das sogar diese letzten sieben, ich weiß jetzt nicht mehr ganz genau. Ich glaube, das war's. Das heißt, es wird dann überhaupt gar keinen G-Part mehr geben, was ja jetzt eh das Ziel war der Bundeswehr, weil man dachte, braucht man nicht mehr. Die sind also jetzt alle in der Ukraine.
Aber nicht nur das, sondern auch diese IRST-Systeme, die hatten wir hier vor einigen Ausgaben schon mal ausführlich besprochen. Zwar mehr aus der Perspektive als Luft-Luft-Rakete, aber es gibt es ja eben auch als Bodenluftsystem.
Und das war wohl sehr effizient mit irgendwie angeblich 100 Prozent Effektivität. Also alles was da irgendwie erfasst wurde, wurde dann auch...
Lokalisiert und zerstört. Dazu eben viele andere Luftabwehrsysteme aus anderen Ländern. Ich kriege die Liste jetzt gar nicht ganz zusammen. Und am Ende ist die Debatte ja so weit eskaliert.
Dann kam es ja diese Situation, dass dann Deutschland den Polen ein Patriotsystem liefern wollte. Das war wohl eh schon abgesprochen. Und die Polen so auch schickt das doch in die Ukraine.
Und Deutschland so, ah, nee, ja, schwierig und so. So haben wir es aber nicht gerechnet. Und dann ging diese ganze politische Debatte los mit, warum denn Deutschland nicht in der Lage ist, mehr zu helfen.
Und am Ende gab es eine Entscheidung der USA, ein Patriotsystem zu liefern. Und dann musste auch Deutschland klein beigeben und das Patriotsystem geht tatsächlich auch in die Ukraine.
Und das ist insofern ein Big Deal, als das natürlich das Patriotsystem als das effizienteste Luftabwehrsystem überhaupt gilt. Ob es das wirklich ist, weiß ich nicht, aber es gilt zumindest als das effizienteste.
Das ist ja jetzt auch nicht nur so ein Ding, was irgendwo rumsteht, wie so ein Gepard, sondern das ist ja sozusagen so ein komplettes Netzwerk aus Radarsystem, Lonsharn etc. Also ein Petrolsystem besteht dann aus, was weiß ich, 7, 8 verschiedenen.
Unterkomponenten, die halt alle miteinander vernetzt sind und dann entsprechend detitieren und dann entsprechend einfliegende Raketen auch zerstören können. Aber das politische
Signal war glaube ich an der Stelle viel, viel, viel wichtiger und in der Folge sind halt zahlreiche Luftabwehrsysteme geliefert worden, sodass die Gesamtsituation sich dann geht, gebessert, dass immer mehr dieser.
Eingehenden Raketen auch abgeschossen werden konnten. Also es gab Tage, wo 80, 90, 95 Prozent aller einflogenden Raketen abgefangen werden konnten.
Die, die dann trotzdem noch irgendwelche Ziele getroffen haben, das war schlimm genug. Aber für die Russen war das natürlich auch sehr teuer, weil diese ganzen Langstreckenraketen, das ist schon somit das teuerste, was du auf den Weg schicken kannst.
Und so viel haben sie davon unter Umständen auch nicht. Wie viel sie jetzt noch haben, das weiß keiner so ganz genau.
Tatsache ist, in letzter Zeit sind die Angriffe seltener geworden und sie sind dann auch immer mit immer weniger Raketen geflogen worden. Das heißt, diese total überwältigenden Massenangriffe haben nachgelassen. Und das hat vielleicht auch damit zu tun,
dass die Ukrainer zu einem Punkt dann auch in der Lage waren, mal ganz anders zurückzuschlagen und es in irgendeiner Form hinbekommen haben, ein Dronensystem
zu starten, was offenbar in der Lage war 600, 700 Kilometer in Russland einzudringen und dort zwei Militärstützpunkte zu treffen, wo genau diese Flugzeuge stehen, mit denen ein Teil dieser.
Langstreckenraketen überhaupt abgefeuert wurde. Und das war natürlich in jederlei Hinsicht bemerkenswert. Erstmal war es bemerkenswert, dass die Ukraine solche Technik hatte. Weiß nicht,
hast du da irgendwelche klaren Erkenntnisse darüber? Also ist man sich jetzt irgendwie mal einig geworden, um was es sich dabei jetzt eigentlich wirklich gehandelt hat?
Ja, das ist also andere Information, habe ich da auch nicht, als dass es sich eben um diese modifizierten TU-141-Drohnen gehandelt hat, in die man dann vorne Sprengstoff reingepackt.
Weil es wurde ja lange gemunkelt, dass es so ein umgebautes Aufklärungsdrohensystem aus so wird es halten.
Hat und die Steuerung halt automatisiert hat. Und ja, das ist also mein letzter Kenntnisstand auch.
Ja, meiner auch. Es gab nur verschiedene Thesen, was es denn auch noch hätte sein können. Und am Ende sah sich die Ukraine jetzt auch nicht genötigt, im Detail zu erklären, was sie da jetzt zum Einsatz gebracht haben.
Weil, warum sollten sie das erzählen? Tatsache ist, sie haben es also geschafft, zwei Airbases anzugreifen in diesem ersten Angriff, die beide 700 Kilometer entfernt waren.
Die sogenannte Engels Airbase und ein weiteres Airfield in der Nähe von Ryazan.
Das sind beides so Standorte, wo Nuklearbomber stehen.
Und das ist insofern was Besonderes, davon gibt es gar nicht so viele in Russland. Also es gibt für ihre dicken Nuklearbomber, glaube ich, überhaupt nur drei oder vier Standorte und das sind zwei davon.
Und wenn halt die Ukraine in der Lage ist, da so eine Drohne hinzuschicken und Bomber zu zerstören und es sieht so aus, als ob sie schon eine oder zwei auch erwischt haben auf diesem Airfield.
Die stehen da nämlich einfach rum ohne Hangare, weil die Russen sich denken, sonst kann ja eh nichts passieren.
Das dürfte also schon mal einerseits recht teuer gewesen sein. Und das Problem ist, dass sie natürlich diese Bedrohung jetzt nach wie vor haben.
Und dann wurden halt ein Großteil dieser Bomber auch auf eine andere Airbase verlegt. Nur die Airbase liegt halt mehrere tausend Kilometer weiter im Osten.
Also eher so in Richtung China und können von dort halt nicht so ohne weiteres gegen die Ukraine eingesetzt werden. Und die können die halt auch nicht auf irgendeinen anderen Flugplatz irgendwo hin schicken,
weil für diese Maschinen brauchst du halt das entsprechende Gerät, Wartung, Material, Personal.
Kannst nicht mal eben einfach irgendwo so einen Bomber irgendwo anders hinstellen, weil dann kriegst du halt unter Umständen da gar nicht mehr weg.
Ein paar Wochen später gab es dann noch einen zweiten Angriff, noch mal auf diese Engels-Airbase.
Auch dessen Auswirkungen werden nur so gerüchteweise bestätigt. Also mal hieß es Bomber sind bestätigt worden, mal hieß es ein Kontrollzentrum ist bestätigt worden oder sogar ein Reparaturbereich.
Weiß ich nicht. Tatsache ist, sie haben es geschafft, das anzugreifen. Sie greifen halt die Russen quasi auf ihrem eigenen Gebiet an, aber eben in so einem militärischen Bereich.
Es gab dann auch noch mal auf der Kursk Airbase auch noch einen Angriff.
Ja, so ein bisschen so ein Duel-Rate-Moment auch. Es sind zwar nur so ein paar Schläge, so wie die Amerikaner nach dem Angriff auf Pearl Harbor,
dann Japan bombardiert haben und wo die Folge dann eben auch war, dass die Japaner dann.
Bestimmte Kräfte zum Schutz des Heimatlandes dann einsetzen mussten und die dann nicht an der Front zum Einsatz bringen konnten.
Auch wenn die Zerstörungen an sich jetzt nicht so groß waren, ist natürlich der strategische
der taktische Effekt ganz gut, dass die Russen sich dann eben einen Kopf drum machen müssen
und Ressourcen dafür aufwenden müssen, die zu schützen und dass es denen komplizierter
macht. Insofern, ja, gute Geschichte.
Ja, gute Geschichte auch dahingehend, wenn man jetzt noch mal diese Distanz misst, diese 700 Kilometer. Also eine Drohne, die sozusagen 700 Kilometer unerkannt oder zumindest unverteidigt durch russisches Land fliegen kann,
um dort dann am Ende auf militärischen Zielen runterzugehen.
Das ist natürlich etwas, was die Russen auf jeden Fall sehr beunruhigen müssen. nicht nur wegen dieser Angriffe, so wie sie bisher stattgefunden haben, sondern 700 Kilometer reicht zum Beispiel auch, um nach Moskau zu fliegen.
Deswegen stehen jetzt auf einigen russischen Ministerien in Moskau jetzt Luftabwehrsysteme. Ich weiß nicht, ob du das gehört hast, dass die...
Ja, genau. Und nicht nur das, auch auf dem Weg dahin. Also es sind sozusagen verschiedene Luftwehrabwehrsysteme auch nochmal abgezogen worden, um eben diese Linie nach Moskau weiter dazu sicher, weil da haben sie natürlich jetzt richtig Schiss, weil da betrifft es ja mal die
Führungskräfte selbst. Ich glaube jetzt nicht, dass die Ukraine anfangen wird, irgendwas auf den Kreml zu schmeißen. Das ist sicherlich, das würde nicht viel bringen.
Also würden irgendwie Putin nicht erwischen und am Ende sich damit mehr Ärger einhandeln, als sie dazu gewinnen haben. Aber die Bedrohung ist natürlich im Raum und es zwingt die Russen
hier auch wiederum sich anders aufzustellen und so ist es halt immer so ein Stellungskrieg,
der auch so auf so einer Mitebene abläuft.
Zwei kleine Dinge noch Ergänzung zur Reaktion des Westens auf diesen Infrastrukturkrieg. Zum einen wurden natürlich jetzt tonnenweise kleine bis große Generatoren geliefert.
Plus die Türken haben sogar ein Generatorschiff nach Odessa geschickt, was quasi Generatoren an Bord hat und dann ein Schiff als Kraftwerk im Grunde genommen.
Mhm. Mhm.
Was ich auch ganz interessant fand.
Und wo wahrscheinlich die Russen auch vielleicht zurückschrecken, davor dieses türkische
Generatorschiff zu bombardieren, aber wer weiß.
Ja, das stimmt. Ja, Generatoren kamen auch aus anderen Ländern. Ich überblicke das nicht. Es war wohl generell schwierig, diese Technik im Westen zu finden,
weil das Russische, also das alte Silvirtische und damit auch das ukrainische Stromnetz auf,
anderen Generatoren-Dimensionen basiert, als das üblicherweise im Westen der Fall ist.
Das heißt, die Generatoren bzw. die Transformatoren, die dort erforderlich sind, die waren jetzt hier nicht so off the shelf verfügbar, aber konnten, glaube ich, aus,
Korea oder so, weiß nicht mehr so ganz genau, unter anderem beschafft werden. Also da ist auf jeden Fall im
im Detail relativ viel passiert und im Großen und Ganzen kann man sagen, das war zwar mal wieder dann sehr teuer für die Ukraine, weil natürlich einiges kaputt gegangen ist, aber die Russen haben Sie jetzt auch nicht klein bekommen darüber.
Und bei uns, falls es jemanden noch nicht aufgefallen ist, bei uns ist auch das Licht nicht ausgegangen und über Weihnachten und ja,
also der Gas, weder das Gas noch dann die entsprechenden Power Outages, die prognostiziert wurden, obwohl die Franzosen auch gerade völlig verkacken.
Irgendwie die Hälfte ihrer Atomkraftwerke gerade nicht laufen.
Aber das ist ein anderes Thema.
Aber wir haben es irgendwie offenbar trotzdem bisher geschafft.
Auch ein bisschen dank des Wetters sicherlich.
Und so ist es auch den Russen nicht gelungen, die Ukraine jetzt zu Boden zu bringen,
zu Fall zu bringen durch ihre Angriffe.
Aber die haben sicherlich für Schäden und Probleme gesorgt.
Genau, und es mag auch die Ukraine in ihrem militärischen Planungsverlauf eingeschränkt haben, weil Dinge nicht produziert werden konnten oder bestimmte Offensiven gegebenenfalls nicht ausreichend abgesichert waren.
Das weiß man nicht, das wird man wahrscheinlich auch nie erfahren und wenn dann erst sehr viel später.
So oder so hat der ganze Krieg um die Infrastruktur die Bereitschaft des Westens weiteres Material bereitzustellen doch deutlich gesteigert. Man hat also
gemerkt wie das eben, ja ich weiß nicht ob das Wort Ruck schon angemessen ist, aber es war auf jeden Fall eine permanente Debatte und führte dann in zunehmenden Maße auch wieder auf die eigentliche Militärtechnik zurück. Und der Ruf nach.
Weiteren Waffenlieferungen, der besteht ja im Prinzip seit Anfang dieses Krieges und ist dann aber immer lauter geworden und vor allem hat er sich in zunehmendem
Maße auf Deutschland verengt, denn die Ukraine wollte vor allem und will nach wie vor vor allem Kampfpanzer haben oder wie es im Englischen etwas präziser heißt Main Battle Tanks, also Hauptkampfpanzer kann man mal sagen.
Wem das vielleicht in der ganzen Debatte noch nicht klar geworden ist,
worum es sich dabei jetzt eigentlich handelt. Man muss halt mal ein bisschen schauen auf die Militärtechnik, wie sie sich so entwickelt hat, insbesondere im Fahrzeugsbereich. Und da kann man so grob ein paar Kategorien unterscheiden.
Da kann man jetzt sehr viele unterscheiden, aber vielleicht einfach nochmal so als generelle Orientierung auch in unserer Debatte darum, worum es jetzt hier eigentlich geht. Man braucht halt Geräte, nicht wahr? Also man braucht überhaupt erst mal Fahrzeuge,
um irgendwie ins Geschehen zu kommen und im Geschehen zu bleiben. Und da kommen natürlich auch teilweise einfache PKW, einfach geschützte Spezial-PKW zum Einsatz. In der Ukraine sind
tonnenweise solche Pickup Trucks unterwegs, wo irgendwie noch ein Gewehr drauf montiert ist.
Das Problem ist nur, das ist natürlich gegen Angriffe nicht besonders gut geschützt. Das ist weder gegen Explosionen gut geschützt noch gegen.
Sniper. Also man will einfach ordentliches Gerät haben und da gibt es halt auf der einen Seite erstmal nur gepanzerte Truppentransporter, also so.
APCs, Armored Personnel Vehicles, die halt einfach dazu da sind, Truppen halbwegs beschützt an den Ort des Einsatzes zu bringen. Aber dann gibt es auch noch weitere
Kategorien wie zum Beispiel die in Deutschland so schönen Schützenpanzer genannte im Englischen,
ich finde auch etwas treffender formuliert sogenannte Infantry Fighting Vehicles. Das sind halt so Minipanzer, die schon etwas größeren Schutzgrad haben, was ihre Panzerung betrifft, die auch eine.
Etwas stärkere Kanone in der Regel mit sich führen, aber die auch primär dafür gedacht sind, einerseits Infanteriegruppen, so in so einer Truppengröße von sieben, acht Leuten, irgendwo hinzufahren,
also schnell irgendwo hinzubringen mit eben so einem Fahrzeug mit Ketten, was halt auch durch.
Jedes Gelände durchkommt, die dort abzusetzen, um sie dort dann bestenfalls noch zu begleiten.
Also, dass man dann eben mit der Kanone versucht, Schutz zu bieten für diese Infanterie, aber im Wesentlichen geht es hier um den Infanterieeinsatz. Das sind diese Marder-Systeme, die jetzt Deutschland vor ein paar Wochen schon zugesagt hat, die zu liefern, nachdem die.
Amerikaner auch ihre Bradley-Panzer, Schützenpanzer zugesagt haben und die Franzosen diese AMX-10-Systeme, also es ist im Prinzip dieselbe Kategorie dieser Infanterie-Fighting-Vehicles. Da hat
sich also jetzt dann doch relativ schnell was getan.
Das sind auch wichtige Fahrzeuge, insbesondere in der Art von Krieg, wie er halt derzeit in der Ukraine herrscht, weil da ist einfach viel Infanterie im Einsatz und es geht eben darum, die Infanterie einfach auch sicher zur Front zu bringen und an der Front gegebenenfalls auch sicher zu unterstützen,
und dann eben auch entsprechend sich wieder zurückziehen zu können, ohne eben sofort Schaden zu nehmen, wenn in der Nähe Artillerie hochgeht. Aber das.
Alleine reicht natürlich nicht aus und deswegen möchte man eben ganz gerne im Verbund auch noch die eigentlichen großen dicken fetten Hauptkampfpanzer
also diese Main Battle Tanks haben und das sind dann halt ebenso Systeme wie die Leopard, Leopard 1, Leopard 2 aus deutscher Produktion, Challenger aus
britischer Produktion oder diese M1 Abrams Panzer aus amerikanischer Produktion, das sind eben auch mit so die leistungsfähigsten Panzer, die es,
eigentlich auch überhaupt gibt und die eben rein von der Kampftechnik her, den russischen Panzermodellen deutlich überlegen sind.
Nur die Amerikaner wollten keine rausrücken, wahrscheinlich einfach auch aus Kostengründen, aus logistischen Gründen die amerikanischen Kampfpanzer laufen auf
anderem Treibstoff. Da macht man jetzt nicht einfach mal nur so Diesel rein, sondern das ist halt so ein Prinzip. Also das kann man wohl auch machen, aber im Wesentlichen sind
es einfach Jet-Engines, die auch extrem viel Sprit brauchen. Also es gab auf jeden Fall viele Ausreden, warum die Amerikaner hier nicht vorangehen wollten und alle haben halt
auf Deutschland gezeigt haben gesagt, hallo Europa, ihr habt da irgendwie ein paar hundert Leoparden rumstehen, da sind von 2000 verkauft worden, das ist seit den 70er Jahren ist das im Wesentlichen der NATO-Standard, wieso nehmt ihr nicht die?
Und Deutschland so, ja nö, machen wir nicht, weil und da wurde es dann etwas unklar, warum sich die deutsche Regierung so schwer getan hat, hier eine
Freigabe für andere Länder zu erteilen, ihre Leoparden bereitzustellen bzw.
Warum sich Deutschland selbst auch nicht bereit erklärt hat, zunächst einmal Leopardpanzer bereitzustellen.
Wir hatten das Thema ja vor Monaten schon mal, was so ein bisschen die deutschen Basisbedenken waren. Auf der einen Seite natürlich das Bild so, deutsche Kampfpanzer im Einsatz auf dem Weg nach Osten Richtung Russland.
Deutsche Kampfpanzer an der Ostfront, so dieses Bild irgendwie, wollte man sicherlich nicht heraufbeschwören. Das ist das eine Ding. Dann, ich sag mal, ganz.
Pragmatische Überlegungen, dass man sich halt jetzt nicht mehr zum Ziel oder zum.
Exponierten Ziel Russlands machen wollte, sondern sagen, wenn, dann liefern alle Panzer, damit jetzt Deutschland nicht so raussticht, was zwar ohnehin nicht ganz
zu vermeiden ist, aufgrund eben der Rolle und der Größe und weil es nun mal deutsche Panzer sind, um die es geht, kommt da Deutschland eine herausragende
Rolle zu, aber man wollte jetzt auch nicht notwendigerweise hier vorne wegmarschieren
oder die Führung übernehmen. Da tut sich Deutschland traditionell mit schwer, teilweise
sicherlich auch aus berechtigten, nachvollziehbaren Gründen. Aber die Situation ist nun mal jetzt auch so, wie sie ist.
Und wenn man sich jetzt auch als Lehrer aus der Nazi-Zeit so dieses nie wieder mitnimmt,
dann heißt das eben aber auch, dass wenn irgendwo anders was passiert,
was in diese Richtung geht, wie sagen wir mal Völkermord und massives Leid, dass man auch nicht einfach nur daneben steht und nichts tut.
So, das ist dann vielleicht die andere politische Lehre oder auch dieses schwierige Spannungsfeld,
natürlich auf der einen Seite zu sagen, nee, wir wollen jetzt Konflikte nicht grundsätzlich mit Waffen befeuern,
Aber man kann eben auch nicht einfach nur daneben stehen.
Da ist halt eher die Frage, ob man mehr nie wieder Krieg oder nie wieder Genozid schreit. So und diese Debatte hatten wir ja schon in der Auseinandersetzung ums Kosovo.
So, da hat sich das ja im Prinzip genauso gezeigt.
Ich war, als unser Außenminister Fischer da klar Position bezogen hat, einfach gesagt hat so, ja, nee, Völkermord darf es in Europa nicht mehr geben.
Und wenn der halt begangen wird, dann müssen wir dagegen auch vorgehen und sich dann halt entsprechenden Kriegs-Skeptikern entgegengesahen, die halt gesagt haben, Also wir wollen ja generell keine Kriegsbeteiligung mehr, weil das macht ja alles nur noch schlimmer.
Kann man so sehen, aber kann man halt auch anders sehen. Ich denke mal, wir beide sind da auch relativ klar positioniert. Wir sehen das auch so, nicht wahr? Also das ist halt einfach, man kann hier nicht nichts tun.
Und man kann sich natürlich eine Welt wünschen, in der keine Panzer mehr irgendwo hinrollen, aber diese Welt ist halt nicht real.
Diese Welt existiert derzeit nicht.
Und dummerweise rollen halt die Panzer und diesmal waren nicht wir, also nicht die Deutschen, die diese Panzer in Bewegung gesetzt haben, sondern es waren die Russen, die halt mit.
Panzern losgezogen sind und das ändert natürlich auch noch mal fundamental die Situation.
Zu der Situation noch mal vielleicht jetzt etwas detaillierter, also warum das Ganze
dann auch so kompliziert lief, lag jetzt nicht nur an der Haltung von Deutschland oder,
Olaf Scholz, der sich ja dagegen gesperrt hat, eben alleine zu liefern oder darauf gepocht.
Hat, dass die USA auch Abrams Panzer liefert, als er es zur Bedingung gemacht hat.
Er wurde dafür kritisiert. Erst war die Position, wir liefern nicht als Erste, sondern wir gehen mit, wenn andere
liefern. hat England dann so seine 14 Challenger Panzer angekündigt, Challenger 2, und dann sagten
okay und jetzt machen wir Deutschland.
Dann sagte Olaf Scholz ja, ja, nee, Amerikaner müssen auch liefern, sonst gehen wir nicht.
Mit und dann musste er sich halt sehr viel Kritik stellen nach dem Motto, ja, er verschiebt.
Immer sozusagen jedes Mal den Zielposten, den Goldpost,
weiß nicht, wie man das Deutsch sagt, aber sozusagen jedes Mal, wenn der Punkt erreicht ist,
so kommen plötzlich neue Dinge, das wurde ihm vorgeworfen.
Stimmt nicht ganz so, ich meine, kann man so oder so interpretieren.
Aber was mir dann aufgefallen ist an der Debatte, dass plötzlich die Abrams-Panzer
so schlecht geredet wurden in der öffentlichen Debatte.
Sagt, es ist zu kompliziert, zu schwer zu warten, brauchen irgendwie Jetfuel und der
amerikanische Verteidigungsminister stellt sich hin und sagt, das ist Quatsch und wir.
Können die nicht warten und die sind zu schwer und die Brücken stürzen alle ein und die.
Passen nicht auf die Züge und was da nicht alles, ja plötzlich waren, waren diese Abrams-Panzer
irgendwie ganz, ganz schlecht für die Ukraine.
Aber Scholz ist dann hart geblieben und bis dann die USA so halb 10 knirschen wahrscheinlich.
Er sagte, na gut, dann liefern wir die jetzt auch, als der Druck zu groß wurde.
Wobei dann auch in den USA-Stimmen gesagt haben, das hätten die USA auch früher haben können. Wenn die USA einfach vor einem
Monat oder vor zwei Monaten gesagt hätten, wir liefern jetzt Abrams-Panzer,
dann wären auch die Deutschen mit dabei gewesen. Das heißt, man kann jetzt nicht
nur Deutschland oder Olaf Scholz allein die Schuld dafür in die.
Schuhe schieben. Und wenn wir jetzt mal ein bisschen wirklich in die Technik.
Rein gehen, nämlich die Frage, wie gut sind denn jetzt die Panzer im Vergleich zueinander?
Dann sind, sagen die Abrams und die Leoparden, gibt es halt in verschiedenen, auch Modernisierungsstufen, deswegen muss man immer aufpassen, was vergleicht man mit was, aber grundsätzlich sind die
beide ziemlich gut.
Und je nach Variante ist mal der eine ein bisschen besser, mal der andere ein bisschen besser. Der Aeros hat wahrscheinlich eine bessere Panzerung, während die neueren Leoparden ab A6.
Haben eine stärkere Kanone, die ist länger, kann weiter schießen und der Leopard gilt halt auch als,
extrem zuverlässig, wobei vor allem die Wanne, also Motor, Laufwerk und so laufen wohl ganz gut.
Schwächen liegen wohl eher im Turm, während Abrams mit der Turbine, wie du schon richtig
gesagt hast, ist aber so, dass gerade Turbinen sind halt besonders, also nehmen jede Art von.
Treibstoff, also alles was brennt im Grunde genommen. Du kannst da auch die Turbine mit.
Diesel betreiben, mit Kerosin, mit Benzin, mit Alkohol, alles was brennt. Auch sogar.
Könntest du sie auch mit Sonnenblumenöl wahrscheinlich in den Tank kippen bei einem,
Abrams Panzer und der würde damit.
Davon gibt es genug in der Ukraine.
Also je nach, ich meine nicht jeder Treibstoff ist dann gleich gut. Manche Treibstoffe bringen dann halt nicht genug Leistung oder weniger Leistung als die 1500 PS, die da rauskommen sollen oder.
Ja, erzeugen ein bisschen mehr Hitze oder Rückstände und so.
Aber Jetfuel wird halt deswegen genommen für die Abrams Kampfpanzer, weil die Kampfflugzeuge alle Jetfuel brauchen und das in großen Mengen verfügbar ist.
Und das ist der einzige Grund, warum normalerweise die Amerikaner den Abrams mit Jetfuel betreiben.
Wobei auch je nach Einsatzgebiet, wie kalt oder heiß es da ist, variiert man dann auch.
Die Sorten. Und letztlich sind das alles mehr oder weniger lange Kohlenwasserstoffketten und so eine Turbine,
die muss in erster Linie brennen. Und die sind halt auch so heiß, dass auch was immer du da reinspritzt, das verbrennt halt und gut ist.
Problem mit dem Abrams ist jetzt, wie gesagt, dass er ungefähr doppelt so viel Sprit verbraucht wie.
Einen Leopard bei vergleichbaren Fahrleistungen und solche Turbinen sind auch nicht so gut im.
Im Leerlauf oder im Teillastbetrieb sind die besonders ineffizient.
Aber um das auch wieder in Perspektive zu setzen,
die Panzer von so einer Panzerbrigade machen ungefähr ein Drittel des Spritverbrauchs aus.
Und so dass wir, wenn man jetzt auf Bataillonsebene, auf Brigadeebene das Ganze betrachtet,
und sagt, wenn wir Abrams versus Leopard einsetzen,
dann haben wir ungefähr ein Sechstel mehr Spritverbrauch. Also es ist jetzt von daher auch nicht so prohibitiv.
An der Stelle, dass man deswegen keine Abrams einsetzen könnte.
Vom Gewicht her und von den Abmessungen her, je nach Variante, sind die praktisch vergleichbar.
Groß.
Also, wenn man sich die anguckt, der Abrams sieht zwar irgendwie klobiger und größer aus, aber wenn ich mir die Millimeter und Zentimeter angucke, die da angegeben sind,
wo im Übrigen die Quellen alle nicht miteinander übereinstimmen.
Selbst wie groß die Panzer wirklich sind, wie lang und breit und hoch, ist nicht eindeutig,
auch eben wegen der verschiedenen Varianten. Aber ich will nur sagen, es gibt Leoparden,
die sind größer als Abrams-Versionen und umgekehrt. Jetzt der eigentliche Haken. Jetzt haben wir ja
gefragt, warum wollen die Amerikaner keine Abrams Panzer liefern? Zumal, wenn man jetzt auch sagt,
Okay, also Abrams dürfte der...
Meistgebaute Kampfpanzer sein, also über 10.000 Abrams-Panzer wurden gebaut, ungefähr 4.000 Leoparden. Davon haben die USA 8.000 Abrams-Panzer,
ungefähr die Hälfte, ich glaube 3.800 sind eingemottet, so sind also gar nicht in Benutzung. Da dachte ich mir, hey, wir haben so viele davon rumstehen, warum, was ist das Problem.
Und brauchen die meisten davon nicht. Und jetzt kam halt dann auch raus, was denn jetzt für Abrams
Panzer geliefert werden und interessanterweise werden keine Bestandspanzer von den Amerikanern
geliefert, sondern 30 bis 40 neu gebaute Panzer, die noch produziert werden.
Müssen. Das ist halt auch so ein bisschen, da haben wir ja gefragt, okay, was ist, gibt es jetzt irgendeinen Haken dran? Also das ist so ein bisschen jetzt der Haken und jetzt.
Fragt man sich natürlich, warum, wenn die USA fast 4000 rumstehen haben, die sie.
Nicht brauchen, produzieren sie jetzt eigentlich neue Panzer für die Ukraine, zumal eigentlich ja jetzt es schnell gehen sollte.
Naja, und Hintergrund ist offenbar, dass die Amerikaner eben nur Exportversionen bereit.
Sind zu exportieren. Der Unterschied zwischen den Exportversionen und den Versionen für die US-Armee ist einmal,
dass die US-Armee halt so eine hochgeheime Panzerung aus abgereichertem Uran hat, die.
Sie wohl einfach nicht rausgeben, obwohl ja an Alliierte vielleicht, also die Abrams,
die dann an Polen gegangen sind.
So die haben halt auch die Uranpanzerung, aber im Moment war jedenfalls erst mal noch der Grund oder ein Grund.
Wir geben aus den Beständen so keine Abrams-Panzer ab.
Dafür, also die USA hat es natürlich brillant geschafft, die Kritik aber dann auf Deutschland zu zu lenken,
während es eigentlich die Amerikaner sind, die ihre Depots, was Panzer angeht, bisher dicht geschlossen halten.
Diese neuen Abrams werden wahrscheinlich über die nächsten zwölf Monate gebaut und geliefert. Der eigentliche Haken daran ist, dass die wahrscheinlich pro Stück irgendwo zwischen,
10 und 20 Millionen Euro kosten werden, die neu produzierten.
Und wie gesagt sind Exportversionen, es sollen angeblich sehr gute Exportversionen sein vom
Abrams, die gleichen, die die Polen dann auch kriegen sollen, also mit modernster Elektronik.
Und allem, aber eben schlechtere Panzerung und wahrscheinlich kriegen die Ukraine auch nicht alle Features, was jetzt so, aber das ist noch unklar.
Ich habe nur gelesen, dass bisher die Exportversion vom Abrams sogar auch beim Antrieb man Abstriche machen musste und an anderen Stellen, also dass die USA einfach die Politik haben.
Wir wollen nicht, dass unsere besten Waffen jetzt einfach überall in der Welt sind, sondern wir wollen halt auch bestimmte Waffen für uns haben,
die einfach besser sind als was alle anderen haben nach Möglichkeit oder zumindest, ja,
wir geben nicht alles ab. Und das ist so das Problem. Und wenn man jetzt davon ausgeht.
Hehehehehehehe, gut, ihr habt gekostet.
Wie gesagt, für jeden dieser Abrams, Kosteteilt jetzt zwischen 10 und 20 Millionen irgendwo
in der Gegend, wären so ein praktisch gleich guter gebraucht Leopard jetzt in der Version
2A6, die wahrscheinlich sogar ein bisschen besser ist als so ein Export Abrams.
Also Leopard A6 hat wie gesagt eine längere Kanone.
Im Prinzip haben Abrams und Leopard 2 die gleiche Kanone bis zur Variante A5 und ab.
A6 und A7 haben längere Kanonen, die natürlich eine höhere Geschossmündungsgeschwindigkeit
ist, schneller am Ziel, kann also besser Objekte in Bewegung bekämpfen, ist zerstörerischer
und einfach besser. Sensorik, schwer zu vergleichen, die wird wahrscheinlich ähnlich gleich gut sein,
so stabilisierte, zweifach stabilisierte Plattformen jetzt für die Periskope und so.
Und auch schießen während der Fahrt und das können die halt alle ganz gut so.
Aber selbst wenn du sagst, okay, so ein Leopard.
2A6 ist ein bisschen besser, dann ist der wahrscheinlich inzwischen halb bis ein Drittel, vielleicht sogar ein Viertel so teuer.
Also das Problem mit diesen neuen Abrams ist einfach, dass man in Leoparden, wenn man das jetzt in Geld misst, wahrscheinlich irgendwie zwei bis vier Mal so viel Bang for the Buck.
Bekommt, wenn man das so sagen darf.
Aber unterm Strich würde ich dann trotzdem nur sagen, ist das eine gute Sache für die Ukraine, dass sie die Abrams kriegen,
wenn nicht dafür die Amerikaner sagen, jetzt waren die Panzer schon so teuer, dafür gibt es halt irgendwie.
Von anderen Dingen, die vielleicht besser gewesen wären, nichts. Dann wäre es eher nicht so gut.
Aber ich denke mal, die politischen Vorteile überwiegen auch und es eröffnet natürlich
auch die Möglichkeit, dass die USA zu einem späteren Zeitpunkt dann doch ihre Depots.
Öffnet und ein paar Tausend von ihren fertigen Abrams nachliefert, die auch gebraucht werden
können. Dazu kommen wir dann noch. Ich möchte jetzt noch mal zusammenfassen.
Wie gut die Panzer sind. Bei den Leoparden muss man eben, wie gesagt, unterscheiden.
Die 2A6 sind ziemlich gut. Das dürften die besten Panzer auf dem Schlachtfeld in der
Ukraine sein, besser als alles, was die Russen haben. Die älteren Versionen, 2A4, 2A5, da,
kommt es dann auf den Modell an. Wie sind da, ist da vielleicht noch die Elektronik aufgerüstet
oder modernisiert worden. Aber die sind jetzt eher von der, sie haben gewisse Schwächen
bei der Panzerung, vor allem am Turm und die Elektronik ist teilweise auch ein bisschen
veraltet, aber wie gesagt, wenn die modernisiert sind, sind die auch besser, also A4, A5 sind.
Auch besser als alles, was die Ukraine hat, aber nicht unbedingt besser als jetzt die
modernsten russischen Kampfpanzer, die im Einsatz sind.
So muss man sich das ungefähr kräftemäßig vorstellen.
Leoparden sind jetzt auch keine Wunderwaffen, aber mit so einem 2A6 kannst du halt schon
das Qualitativ wahrscheinlich zwei, vier, fünf mal überlegen und der Vorteil ist gerade bei so
so einem A6 oder so, die haben...
Teilweise extrem gute Optiken, wo man auf drei, vier Kilometer noch bei Nacht ein Ziel erkennen und anvisieren kann und dann extrem schnell vom Kommandanten zum Schützen übergeben die Zielposition.
Der bekämpft dann das Ziel, während der Kommandant schon ein weiteres Ziel sich angucken kann und wie gesagt mit dem schnellen Feuerleitsystem und auch in der Bewegung und so.
Also die entfalten da glaube ich schon dann eine gewisse Wirkung, aber trotzdem, wenn da jetzt.
Ich sage mal fünf oder zehn russische alte Panzer stehen, machst du auch mit so einem 2A6.
Unter Umständen nichts mehr. Also so muss man das in etwa sehen.
Wie gesagt Abrams dann auch gut Exportvariante ja okay, aber super teuer und verbraucht viel Sprit.
Und dann Challenger 2, was die Briten liefern wollen, ist sehr gut gepanzert, hat aber eine
schwächere Kanone, aber kann eben auch als einziger sogenannte Hash Munition, High Explosive Scoreshed,
sogenannte Quetschkopf-Munition verschießen, die wohl besonders gut auch zur Bekämpfung von.
Bunkern oder Gebäuden oder Befestigungen geeignet ist. Und die wirkt auch irgendwie gleich gut,
selbst wenn man im Winkel schießt, weil wenn diese Munition auftrifft, dann ist die quasi
sie breitet sich aus. Es ist halt wie so ein Stück Knete, kann man sagen, und breitet sich
dann aus und explodiert dann und erreicht ebenso ihre Wirkung. Aber generell Challenger 2 war.
So ein Alleingang der UK. Das englische Militär hätte lieber den Leoparden gehabt, aber Politik
hat gesagt, nee, wir können keine deutschen Panzer hier kaufen als Briten, das kannst du
vielleicht verstehen, so dass man dann irgendwie den Challenger 2 gebaut hat. Wie sagt super gut
gepanzert, dafür auch extrem schwer. Einziger mit einer gezogenen Kanone, mit niedrigerer
Geschossgeschwindigkeit, eigene Munition, die nicht kompatibel ist mit dem Rest der NATO oder.
Mit Leopard oder Abrams und wird seit 10 oder 15 Jahren nicht mehr produziert,
auch keine Ersatzteile mehr. Das heißt, als die Produktion damals dicht gemacht,
wurde, ich glaube 2003 oder so, hat man noch genug Ersatzteile produzieren lassen
und auf Lager gelegt, um die noch eine Weile zu betreiben. Aber ja, Britten habe ich in der
Größenordnung von 200 davon.
300 und 100 davon benutzen sie gar nicht. Die könnten sie eigentlich sofort abgeben und mit dem Rest können sie eigentlich auch nicht viel anfangen.
Aber der Punkt ist natürlich, wenn sie die jetzt schicken, dann ist alles, was jetzt noch an Munition und Ersatzteilen da ist, ist dann auch weg. Also eigentlich können die Briten entweder nur so eine Token-Force,
Wobei wahrscheinlich die selbst eine Kompanie, diese 14 Challenger, die sie schicken, werden wahrscheinlich den Briten ihre gesamte Challenger Munition verschießen, die sie noch auf Lager haben.
Also, ja, von daher so eine andere komische Situation.
Im Grunde genommen könnten die Briten alle ihre Challenger IIs an die Ukraine geben und sagen, okay, das war es dann mit unseren Challenger und wir decken uns woanders ein.
Und die werden dann in der Ukraine jetzt verschrottet. Aber da ist das Problem, dass sie nichts haben zum Üben.
Dann müssten sie irgendwo. Aber die könnten sich von den Amerikanern irgendwie 1000 oder ein paar hundert Bradleys hinstellen lassen. Also insgesamt gibt es genug Panzer, die geliefert werden könnten.
Aber das vielleicht ja, wie sich, wie sich das mit der Technik gestaltet.
Und deswegen kann man vielleicht auch nachvollziehen, warum die Amerikaner jetzt nicht so begeistert waren, Abrams in die Ukraine zu liefern, weil
sie wissen, dass es halt teuer ist. Es gab dann außerdem noch den Verdacht, dass der,
Plan der Amerikaner vielleicht eher der ist, dass die Europäer alle ihre Leopard-2-Panzer.
In die Ukraine geben und dann die Amerikaner den allen als Ersatz Bradleys verkaufen können.
Und wenn sie selber, nicht Bradley, Abrams, sorry, ich habe mich versprochen, dass sie.
Statt Leopardpanzern, aber das sind doch Schützenpanzer. Also Airbraims meist so.
Dann quasi, die Europäer liefern die Leoparden an die Ukraine, da werden die kaputt gemacht,
und die USA können dann sagen, den europäischen Panzermarkt mit Abrams-Panzern aufräumen.
Naja, also ich glaube, das wird nicht passieren. Die Frage ist eher, was wird jetzt mit der deutschen Rüstungsindustrie, die ja auch teilweise eine französische Rüstungsindustrie ist.
Also hier einer von den beiden großen Konzernen gehört ja auch zum französischen oder teilweise zum französischen Konsortium.
Auf jeden Fall.
Hat diese ganze Debatte natürlich mehrere politische Dimensionen. Also erst mal kann man natürlich sagen, OK, gut, war jetzt wieder ein zähes Ring.
Aber die Entscheidung ist auf dem Platz so, es wird jetzt stattfinden. hätte alles viel früher sein können, aber lieber spät als zu spät. Und was hier zu spät ist, ist eh offen.
Die nächste Debatte wird natürlich dann um die Mengen gehen. Weil jetzt mit 14 Panzern aus Deutschland alleine wirst du diesen Krieg nicht gedreht bekommen. Und klar, andere Länder haben mehr, aber alles werden sie auch nicht.
Abgeben können und wollen, sollten sie vielleicht auch nicht unbedingt tun. Also es ist eine Frage auch der Nachproduktion und Panzer, die einfach hier so rumstehen. Ich meine, es gibt hier auch ein riesiges Feld irgendwo, wo so eine Firma die ganzen Leopard 1 irgendwie aufgekauft hat,
die glaube ich jetzt mittlerweile wieder vom Rüstungskonzern zurückgekauft wurden. Also im Prinzip stehen da irgendwie so Leos rum, dann denkt man sich ja auch so, was mit denen hier,
Hier leo 1 und so weiter besser als nix.
Uralt panzer aber Das sind sowieso nur uralt panzer unterwegs und mit leo 1 könnte man im prinzip ja auch noch was reißen Problem ist nur die dinger stehen halt unter umstehen seit 20 30 jahren rum.
Ja sind da abgestellt worden die sind nicht irgendwie fein gereinigt worden vorher bevor sie eingemottet wurden sondern da ist irgendwie noch Öl drin und keine Ahnung. Im Prinzip müsstest du halt diese ganzen alten Panzer einmal komplett auseinandernehmen.
Feinwaschen, neu machen und Stück für Stück wieder zusammensetzen. Alle Verschleißteile, alle Filter, Dichtungen, Gummi, was auch immer.
Also alles, was von der Zeit und vom Wetter zersetzt ist, muss alles neu gemacht werden.
Das kostet erstmal eine Menge Zeit, kostet auch eine Menge Geld. Und darüber hinaus hast du diese Teile unter Umständen auch gar nicht.
Also die werden einfach gar nicht mehr produziert bzw. sind nicht vorrätig. sodass auch hier nochmal für die Reaktivierung dieser Panzer komplette Industrie wieder hochgefahren werden muss oder zumindest in irgendeiner Form ein Maschinenbau-Workflow erstellt werden muss.
Kann man sich ja durchaus auch vorstellen heutzutage mit moderner Technik, Pipapo, aber jetzt einfach so einen 3D-Drucker anschmeißen, damit ist es natürlich auch nicht getan, weil natürlich dann hier auch die Stähle bestimmte Anforderungen genügen müssen etc. Steckt da im Detail nicht
drin, aber das ist auf jeden Fall der Rahmen, in dem sich das Ganze abspielt. Die Leo 2, da ist es ähnlich, also auch die müssen halt teilweise wieder.
Aktiviert werden erst, also die fährst nicht einfach aus der Garage und direkt an die Front und so. Und ein weiterer Aspekt bei diesem ganzen, wann kommt denn das hier alles zum Einsatz und kommt das in ausreichendem Maße zum Einsatz, ist natürlich auch etwas, was du jetzt auch ein bisschen weggelassen hast bei dieser ganzen Diskussionen um die Abrams. Es geht ja nicht nur darum taugt das.
Gerät als solches vor Ort, sondern es ist ja auch was ist wenn das Ding kaputt ist, was ist wenn das Ding angeschossen ist, wo kommen die Teile her, mit welchen
Maschinen kannst du das Ding überhaupt wieder in Bestand nehmen. Ist ja nicht so, dass jetzt einfach nur mit dem Schraubenschlüssel da rangeht, sondern du brauchst ja
teilweise auch spezielles Gerät, du brauchst spezielles Messgerät, du brauchst spezielle digitale Systeme, du brauchst Technik, du brauchst Ersatzteillager, du brauchst Logistik, die das Ganze auch zum richtigen Zeitpunkt in der richtigen Menge an den richtigen Ort bringt.
Du brauchst Personal, was damit umgehen kann etc. pp. Und das spricht natürlich alles sehr viel mehr für die europäischen Panzer, weil die natürlich sehr viel näher dran sind, aber auch mit den Leos hast du dasselbe Problem.
Bei amerikanischen Panzern ist es halt noch mal extra. So. Und von daher ist mit der Entscheidung, die jetzt gefällt, es zwar in irgendeiner Form mal wieder ein weiterer Schritt gegangen worden,
aber wir sind noch sehr weit davon entfernt, dass jetzt wirklich eine funktionierende Kampfkraft daraus entsteht,
die wirklich die Ukraine bald in die Lage versetzt, hier den nächsten Schritt zu gehen.
Also um mal was zu Dimensionen zu sagen, also erstmal was jetzt die Produktion angeht. Es ist mir nicht gelungen herauszufinden, wie groß denn jetzt die Leopard-Panzerproduktionskapazität ist.
Also wie viel jetzt neue Leoparden zum Beispiel im Monat produziert werden können oder wie viel im letzten Jahr neu produziert wurden zum Beispiel.
Und vermutlich keine oder wenn dann nur eine einstellige Zahl im ganzen letzten Jahr. Das ist nach meinem bestes Wissen, weil man eben bisher in der Abrüstung war und wenn,
dann war es günstiger, einfach Altbestände zu modernisieren.
Statt jetzt komplett neue Leopard-2-Panzer zu bauen, weil das ungefähr die Hälfte kostet. Also die Bundeswehr hat jetzt auch für Ankauf und für die Modernisierung von Leopard-2-Panzern.
Dann so 7 Millionen ungefähr für einen aktuell modernisierten Leopard-2-Panzer.
Gebraucht, aber dann auf neuesten Stand gebracht, während neu wahrscheinlich du eher fast das Doppelte bezahlst.
Das heißt, wahrscheinlich werden sämtliche Einzelteile für einen Leopard 2 noch produziert, werden aber nur selten zu kompletten Neupanzern zusammengesetzt.
Das ist wahrscheinlich weshalb das so ein bisschen unklar ist. Amerikaner dagegen, hauen regelmäßig wohl weiter Panzer raus jetzt.
Also Größenordnungsmäßig, ich weiß nicht, zwischen 10 und 30 im Monat so eine Panzerfabrik,
an Abrams-Panzern. Das heißt, die 30 oder 40 Stück, die da jetzt an die Ukraine gehen, je nachdem wie weit
sie die vorziehen, so gibt es schon eine gute Chance, dass das nicht Jahre dauert,
bis die produziert werden können. Das ist jetzt die Produktionssituation. Was jetzt die ganze Logistik angeht, wie du richtig gesagt hast, ist es natürlich besser,
du hast nur eine Sorte von Panzer, sei mal wegen der Logistik.
Aber es ist jetzt auch nicht so, dass diese Panzer jetzt über das ganze Land verteilt werden
und du jetzt ein landesweites Logistiknetz hast, sondern idealerweise stattest du so,
eine Brigade komplett mit derselben Art von Panzern aus.
So eine Brigade, da hast du dann eben auch die ganzen Bergefahrzeuge mit dabei, eine gewisse
Instandsetzungsinfrastruktur und so eine Brigade, muss man sich vorstellen, sind so 3000 bis 5000,
Mann, die unter anderem dann größtensordnungsmäßig 80 Kampfpanzer haben. Die 14 Stück, die jetzt
immer geliefert werden, ist ungefähr das, womit man eine Kompanie ausstatten kann. Aber auf
auf Kompanieebene hast du natürlich weniger Supportfahrzeuge und so und praktisch keine
Wartung oder so, also in jeden Fall wenig, sondern in Standhaltung ist dann eher woanders.
Was die Besatzung nicht kann, das wird dann auch nicht in der Kompanie mehr gemacht.
Aber in anderen Worten, ich glaube, dass alles, was so die Größenordnung von 100 Panzern
oder so, also 80 bis 100, wenn du eine Brigade damit ausstatten kannst, dann ist es okay,
weil eine andere Brigade kann dann ruhig einen anderen Panzer haben und mit der eben passenden Supportinfrastruktur, so würde ich das in etwa sehen.
Sprich immer 14 von dem einen und 14 von dem anderen und 14 vom dritten in eine Brigade zu packen,
wäre dann in der Tat ein bisschen blöd.
Aber sobald man irgendwie in die 100er-Größenordnung kommt oder 70, 80, macht es Sinn.
Das heißt, es würde auch Sinn machen, wenn England jetzt eine Brigade mit Challenger 2 ausstatten könnte.
Die Amerikaner haben jetzt 30 bis 40 commit und ich habe dann mal versucht, was jetzt an Leoparden angekündigt ist.
Und da kommt man.
Auf bis zu 150, die jetzt erst mal geliefert werden könnten, wobei da, ich weiß nicht, 40 oder 50 spanische Leoparden dabei sind, von denen ein Großteil so runtergerockt ist,
dass die Tschechen, die die kaufen wollten, nach der Besichtigung dankend abgewunken.
Haben und gesagt haben, behaltet mal die Wommer nicht.
Und wenn nicht mal die Tschechen, die irgendwie für billig Geld haben wollten, da geht man
davon aus, dass ein Teil davon doch noch erheblich überarbeitet werden muss.
Während die 14 Deutschen, würde mich nicht wundern, wenn die schon unterwegs wären oder schon irgendwo in der Ukraine wären.
Weil die werden, soweit ich das verstanden habe, direkt aus der aktiven Truppe rausgenommen.
Das heißt, das sind, meines Wissens, Panzer, die vielleicht letzte Woche noch gefahren sind. Also die kommen quasi aus dem aktiven Dienst.
Dafür können Sie ja noch andere Panzer nutzen und das ist natürlich einfach auch in der.
Aber würde es nicht sehr viel mehr Sinn machen, die erstmal hier zur Ausbildung zu nutzen.
Ukraine auszubilden und die müssen ja irgendwann darüber. Wer weiß, vielleicht ist auch einiges an Ausbildung schon gelaufen.
Also ich will nur sagen, es wird nicht lange dauern, bis die deutschen A6 an der Front sind oder sein könnten.
Oder sagen wir in der Ukraine sein könnten, wenn man will.
Ja gut, wenn sie in die Front kommt, das ist ja nochmal eine ganz andere Frage, die nur teilweise mit der Verfügbarkeit und der Logistik zu tun hat, sondern natürlich auch wo es Sinn macht.
Aber so oder so steht hier noch eine große Umstellung für die ukrainische Armee an.
Also, die sind natürlich bereit dazu, sich auf diese Technologie zu werfen. Allein schon deshalb, weil es natürlich auch für die Ukraine die Zukunft ist.
Das ist ja mal absehbar und das haben wir ja auch schon ein paar Mal erwähnt, dass wir hier eigentlich in großer Vorspulgeschwindigkeit dabei zusehen,
wie ein Land komplett von sowjetischer Militärtechnik auf NATO-Militärtechnik umgestellt wird, in allen Bereichen.
Das haben wir jetzt schon vorher gesehen mit den Flugabwehrsystemen, sicherlich demnächst auch mit den leichteren Schusswaffen.
Dann werden wir das sehen bei der Artillerie, dass auf die 155 mm Artillerie gewechselt wird.
Und dass natürlich jetzt im nächsten Schritt dann auch die ganzen Schützenpanzer und Main Battle Tanks entsprechend dort eingeführt werden.
Mal ganz einfach abgesehen, dass wahrscheinlich im eigentlichen Kommunikationsbereich, wo Funkstandards etc. Befehlsketten und diese ganze Verquickung dieser ganzen Geräte,
die ganze komplexe Gesamtsteuerung eines Militärapparats auch in zunehmenden Maße sich da vernatrufiziert, allein schon um mit der NATO derzeit gut zusammenarbeiten zu können.
Ein anderer Aspekt noch, weil ich ein Thema Brigade, damit man sich das noch ein bisschen besser vorstellen kann, diese 80 Kampfpanzer, das ist jetzt auch wichtig für die nächste
Frage, wie viel braucht die Ukraine denn zum Gewinnen eigentlich?
Aber es sind ja nicht nur Panzer, sondern die Panzer sind ja nur ein Teil, zwar ein wichtiger, sehr prominenter Teil, sagen wir mal jetzt einer Panzerbrigade oder generell
von halt motorisierten Streitkräften. Aber du hast typischerweise dann auch noch in.
So einer Brigade, die dann 80 Panzer hat, hast du dann ungefähr nochmal 150 bis,
200 Infanterie-Fighting-Vehicles oder Panzerkampfwagen, Schützenpanzer, wie auch
immer. Du hast dann bis zu 20, 30, 60, ungefähr 60 Tankfahrzeuge. Also je nach dem. Also so eine
amerikanische Brigade mit 80 Panzern hat dann Transportkapazität, also alleine um.
Ungefähr 750.000 Liter Sprit zu transportieren, so auf 15 großen Tanklastzügen mit die 19.000 Litern
und 48 Tankfahrzeugen, wo 9.500 Liter draufpasst. Das heißt, du hast ungefähr,
ich glaube ja bei den früher, den Witz oder so, dass bei Autos, dass da ein Tankwagen hinterher
fahren muss, die viel verbrauchen. So ist das ungefähr auch bei so einer Brigade. Also,
Also pro Panzer ungefähr auch noch ein Tankfahrzeug, wobei diese Tankfahrzeuge natürlich auch den.
Ganzen Rest dort mit versorgen.
Da gehören dann natürlich auch weitere Fahrzeuge dazu, wie HMWs zum Beispiel oder MRAPs oder so,
Plus Artillerie, plus andere Dinge.
Also am Ende des Tages verbrauchen die Panzer, wie ich vorhin schon gesagt habe, wahrscheinlich
so ungefähr ein Drittel des Spritzes eines Bataillons, einer Brigade.
Und eine Brigade, deswegen so die Größenordnung, weil das ist, sagen die, ja, so ein bisschen
die ideale Self-Contained-Einheit, wie in der Marine. Du Kreuzer hast, die auch alleine
unterwegs sein könnten, ist so eine Brigade, auch was ziemlich viel dabei hat, um sich
selbst zu reparieren und zu versorgen und so.
Und bei der Frage, wie viel Kampfpanzer braucht jetzt die Ukraine umzugewinnen? Also der ukrainische Verteidigungsminister Resnikow hatte mal von 300 Kampfpanzern gesprochen.
Jetzt sind es schon 400 geworden, aber klar, das werden natürlich je länger es geht, umso mehr Panzer gehen auch kaputt von den existierenden Panzern und die Zahl wird halt einfach nur steigen.
Also 400 Panzer war jetzt sozusagen die Wunschzahl.
Die sagt, ungefähr 100, 150 sind bisher zugesagt.
Aber die Frage, die ich mir gestellt habe, reichen denn die 400 auch aus?
Also Resnikow hat gesagt, ja, diese drei oder vierhundert Panzer, Wobei man im Kopf natürlich immer dann mitlesen muss 300 Panzer plus dann nochmal 500 Panzerkampffahrzeuge plus plus plus.
Also diese Panzer sind, wenn wir von einem Panzer reden, hängt da eben immer noch ein gewisser Rattenschwanz mit dran.
Aber mit 300 bis 400 Panzern kann man so nachdem 4 bis 5 Brigaden ausstatten.
So eine Brigade hat 3000 bis 5000 Mann, also wir reden dann so von 15 bis 25.000 Soldaten.
Ungefähr, die man braucht, um 300 bis 400 Panzer zu bedienen.
Die Ukraine hat jetzt ungefähr wahrscheinlich eine Million Soldaten im Einsatz.
Und das sind aber jetzt nicht alles gepanzerte Brigaden, sondern aktuell bestehen die Bodenstreitkräfte,
aus 33 Brigaden mechanisierter Infanterie.
Davon wurden zehn nach Kriegsbeginn aufgestellt, sowie fünf Panzerbrigaden.
Und ich habe ausgerechnet, dass allein nur die aktuellen ukrainischen Bodenstreitkräfte.
Sozusagen mit den 33 Brigaden und fünf Panzerbrigaden, 38, also das sind ungefähr 200.000 Leute.
Und die könnten, um jetzt NATO-mäßig ausgerüstet zu sein,
eigentlich 3000 Kampfpanzer gebrauchen.
Haben tun sie aktuell wohl eher um die 1000. Also vielleicht etwas weniger, vielleicht etwas mehr.
Also die russischen Beutepanzer waren wohl teilweise in erbärmlichem Zustand
und werden noch aufgearbeitet aktuell.
Gleichzeitig gehen natürlich Panzer verloren, auch auf ukrainischer Seite durch Verschleiß und Zerstörung.
Also wahrscheinlich auch ein, zwei, drei Dutzend im Monat gehen auch den Ukraniern sicherlich verloren.
So dass im Grunde genommen um jetzt die ukrainischen Bodenstreitkräfte, die schon vorhanden sind,
nur normal auszustatten, reden wir von 2000 Kampfpanzern, die sie eigentlich bräuchten.
Das heißt jetzt nicht, dass es, ja und die Russen dürften so noch ungefähr 1500 in der Ukraine im Einsatz haben und haben wohl eine Jahresproduktion, nachdem gemunkelt wird von bis zu 300 Kampfpanzern.
Und haben aber noch erhebliche Mengen an Altpanzern, die sie jetzt auch aufarbeiten, sodass halt auch die Russen noch, ja, da wird auch potenziell noch was mit dazukommen.
Aus meiner Sicht, so wie ich das sehe, bräuchten wir, wenn, da kommen wir später drauf, wenn.
Es nicht gelingt, jetzt in den nächsten Monaten oder bis nächsten Sommer, Herbst oder so,
entscheidende Erfolge zu erzielen mit kleineren Mengen, dann wird quasi die Zahl, die die
Ukraine braucht, in die Tausende von Kampfpanzern gehen, um in 2024 dann die Russen rauszutreiben,
wenn die halt nachgezogen haben.
Aber wie gesagt, davon später. Aber einen Unterschied machen natürlich ein paar hundert westliche Kampfpanzer schon aus.
Weil am Ende geht es auch darum, Kräfte dann wiederum zu konzentrieren irgendwo und eventuell
an mehreren Fronten zu konzentrieren. Das heißt, es ist jetzt nicht nichts, aber die 100 Panzer, die jetzt oder 150 Panzer
in den nächsten zwölf Monaten, die jetzt angekündigt sind, ist jetzt meiner Sicht
fast zwei Größenordnungen zu gering.
Ne, 4000.
Die Frage ist natürlich, können überhaupt mehr hergeholt werden? Also ich meine, wenn überhaupt nur 2000 produziert worden sind von den Leoparden, wo willst du dann 2000?
Ja gut, aber die sind ja dann auch, also jetzt nur Leopard 2 oder generell Leopard?
Ja, ja, in Leopard 2 glaube ich auch.
Gut, aber die sind ja auch nicht alle in Europa, die sind natürlich nicht alle verfügbar. Also du kommst nicht so ohne weiteres auf eine vierstellige Zahl, die verfügbar sein könnte.
Die Amerikaner haben 3.800 Bradley rumstehen, 4.000 im aktiven Einsatz.
Ja gut, die Schützenpanzer. Ich rede jetzt von den Leopard. Du redest doch jetzt von.
Abrams, ich rede von Abrams, ich meinte Abrams.
Die haben 3.800 Abrams rumstehen und ich vermute mal, man könnte auch noch 1.000 Leoparden
zusammenkratzen, wenn man wollte insgesamt.
Ja, müsste man halt ich auch. So und ich meine damit endet natürlich die Ausgabe noch nicht. Vielleicht sollten wir mal kurz ein bisschen wegkommen auch jetzt von der reinen Panzer-Perspektive.
Die nächste Debatte tut sich ja jetzt schon auf und dann geht es ja dann auch um Flugzeuge. Also ein Rückschlag. Der Russen kann nicht nur und sollte auch nicht nur über den Boden erfolgen.
Es ist nicht so, dass man jetzt einfach nur mit Panzern vorrückt und dann ist schon alles super. Es gibt ja dann auch noch die Luft. Bisher konnte Russland dort nicht viel erreichen.
Das hat was mit der guten Luftabwehr zu tun. Das hat viele Gründe. Also die ganze Luftwaffe der Ukraine ist ja noch intakt, aber halt auch nicht top aktuell.
Und jetzt geht natürlich der Ruf nach den F-16-Flugzeugen los. Ich denke, das ist so die Debatte, die wir so im nächsten Monat vor allem sehen werden, dass jetzt hier
noch aufgestockt wird. Abgesehen davon, dass die Zahlen jetzt auch noch mal erhöht werden müssen. Aber das war natürlich jetzt erstmal der wichtige
Schritt war die generelle Bereitschaft, so nach dem Motto, wir machen das jetzt im Prinzip und die Zahlen sind jetzt debattierbar, aber es ist jetzt kein
großer Unterschied zwischen wir liefern 20 Panzer oder wir liefern 50 Panzer, wenn generell überhaupt erstmal entschieden ist, dass die geliefert werden und das dafür die entsprechende Ausbildung geleistet wird, die Logistik dafür aufgebaut wird etc. pp und vielleicht eben auch neue produziert werden. Das.
Wahrscheinlich ohnehin. Also ich denke mal, es ist jetzt auch eine Frage, in wiefern Europa in der Lage ist, seine Kriegsmaschinerie entsprechend zu tunen, um dann eben auch hier nachliefern zu können für das, was abgegeben wird.
Letztendlich steht da eine große Modernisierung auch an.
Also mit den Kampfpanzern oder dann nochmal mit neuen Kampfflugzeugen, F-16 oder was auch immer, das sind natürlich extrem komplexe Systeme auch, deren Einführung normalerweise in dem Militär viele, viele Jahre dauert.
Also nicht nur was jetzt die ganze Wartung angeht, sondern einfach auch nur zu lernen, wie man die Dinger richtig bedient und wie man mit den Dinger am besten kämpft.
Wobei, ja, man wahrscheinlich, das Leute sind die grundsätzlich schon wissen,
wie man mit Panzern umgeht oder also Ausbildung dauert wohl irgendwie vier bis sechs Monate, die man eigentlich braucht, um Leute mit so einem Panzer dann wirklich guten Gewissens in den Kampf.
Schicken zu können. Und es ist eben auch viel Panzer, jetzt Flugzeug, ja Piloten trainieren,
sagen wir mal eher Jahre, wobei, wenn ich sechs bis zwölf Monate wahrscheinlich,
wie lange das umtrainieren dauert weiß ich nicht aber der eigentliche punkt ist.
Das ist eben ein riesiger logistischer Aufwand, auch weil dieser Rattenschwanz dranhängt, weil du noch das ganze Drumherum brauchst und eben auch Panzerkampfwagen und Tanklaster und Brückenlegepanzer und Bergefahrzeuge und dafür auch die Leute wiederum ausbilden.
Musst, diese speziellen Systeme zu bedienen und dann natürlich die Lieferung von all diesen verschiedenen Dingen auch zu koordinieren, da entstehen natürlich erhebliche Opportunitätskosten.
Also sprich, du kannst als jetzt, weiß nicht, Regierung oder Verwaltung oder Militär nur.
So und so viele Dinge gleichzeitig vernünftig koordinieren.
Und wenn du einfach zu viel gleichzeitig versuchst zu machen, dann geht halt auch entsprechend mehr schief. war das mit den Panzern auch so, dass das vor einem halben Jahr wahrscheinlich noch
verfrüht gewesen wäre, weil es viel zu viele andere, dringendere Dinge zu koordinieren.
Gab. Im Moment ist die Zeit vielleicht ganz gut, aber sie wäre auch schon vor zwei Monaten ganz gut gewesen.
Also wir hätten eigentlich schon vor zwei Monaten idealerweise begonnen mit den Panzerlieferungen
oder die Entscheidung vor zwei Monaten getroffen. Und mit den Flugzeugen, mit den F-16 sieht es halt ähnlich aus.
Also das ist jetzt nicht unbedingt gerade das Dringendste
und insbesondere jetzt im Hinblick auf die Offensiven, die man dann plant oder Einsatz an der Front.
Ist nicht davon auszugehen, dass man jetzt mit Hilfe von F-16 in absehbarer Zeit dann Lufthoheit erlangt oder auch gar nur jetzt diese zur Unterstützung an der Front einsetzen könnte oder würde.
Was man halt wofür die nützlich wären. Die F-16 wäre eben Luftpatrouillen über dem ukrainischen Luftraum zu fliegen
und die russischen Flugzeuge auf Abstand zu halten und eventuell Cruise Missiles zu bekämpfen und abzufangen.
Aber die Offensiven in 2023 von welcher Seite auch immer werden wohl ohne allzu viel Luftunterstützung stattfinden,
einfach weil auf beiden Seiten eben auch die bodengestützte Luftabwehr so stark ist.
Dass in Frontnähe der Einsatz von Flugzeugen einfach extrem riskant ist.
Und die Russen haben das jetzt auch gerade letzte Woche gemerkt,
wo sie dann, glaube ich, drei Kampfflugzeuge und einen Hubschrauber in einem Tag verloren haben.
Und ähnlich würde es den Ukrainern auch gehen. Insofern, ja, wenn man jetzt langfristig guckt, so braucht die Ukraine sicherlich auch wieder eine Luftwaffe,
Aber wahrscheinlich wird die jetzt erstmal nicht an der Front allzu relevant sein.
Gut, das mag sein, aber es ist ja letzten Endes hier auch ein langfristiges Ziel, weil es ist ja mittlerweile absehbar, dieser Konflikt wird noch eine Weile anhalten.
Ich meine, wir hatten alle so ein bisschen die Hoffnung, dass dieses Momentum sich halten kann und das hätte vielleicht auch funktioniert, wenn das Wetter mitgespielt hätte, wenn entsprechende Munitionslieferungen,
Waffenlieferungen in einem höheren Maße geleistet worden wären, als sie es wurden.
Genau kann ich es nicht sagen, ob es jetzt hier extrem gemangelt hat an Unterstützung und wenn ja, woran es lag. Aber offensichtlich ist halt einfach das Problem existiert. Das Problem scheint im Übrigen aber auch bei den Russen zu existieren. Also auch dort wird Munition zumindest derzeit.
Etwas rationiert. So und es herrscht derzeit deutlich weniger Artillerieaktivität. Das kann sich natürlich auch wieder ändern. Also will ich sagen, es ist absehbar, dass wir.
Noch in einem halben Jahr immer noch mit diesem Krieg an einem Punkt stehen werden, wo man sagen muss, weitere Dinge müssen geschehen, um Russland weiter in Griff zu kriegen. Verschiedene Faktoren können natürlich jetzt sich.
Positiv auswirken, also jenseits der Frage, gibt es genug gerät, ist natürlich die Frage, wie entwickelt sich die russische Gesellschaft.
Weiter? Wie entwickelt sich die russische Wirtschaft weiter? Die ganzen Sanktionen sind jetzt nicht ohne Auswirkungen. Sie haben noch nicht jetzt dazu geführt, dass das ganze
System dort kollabiert, aber es ist halt schon so, dass sich es eigentlich für niemanden die Situation verbessert hat, aber sich die Situation schon für viele Leute verschlechtert. Das sind halt auf der einen Seite die Leute, die eben...
In den Krieg eingezogen wurden, dort kämpfen müssen, dort gestorben sind, die Angehörige verloren haben. Das sind natürlich Auswirkungen, die sich in zunehmendem Maße dort manifestieren.
Du hast die Auswirkungen auf die Wirtschaft, allein dadurch, dass die Leute in den Krieg abgezogen werden oder vor ihm flüchten. Das haben wir ja auch schon mehrfach thematisiert. Hunderttausende fehlen hier der Wirtschaft und das wird nicht ohne Wirkung bleiben.
Dann gibt es neue Sanktionen gegen den Ölverkauf Russlands. Die ganz pfiffig ausgeheckte Ölpreisbremse, die hier ausgerufen wurde,
funktioniert ja über die Dominanz des Westens über den Versicherungsmarkt.
Das bedeutet, dass man eben unter anderem, aber ich glaube, das ist der wesentliche Faktor, Sprich, das läuft so, die Tanker, die halt das Öl, das russische Öl, irgendwo hinbringen auf diesem Planeten, brauchen natürlich auch eine Versicherung.
Diese Versicherung dürfen aber von westlichen Versicherungsunternehmen nur noch dann erbracht werden, wenn der Preis des verkauften Öls unter einem laufend aktualisierten Preislevel liegt. derzeit so irgendwo so bei 60 US-Dollar, glaube ich, pro barrel. Was ein Preis ist, der es den Russen
sozusagen gerade mal erlauben würde, mehr oder weniger zum Selbstkostenpreis zu produzieren.
Und also relativ wenig Gewinn oder fast gar kein Gewinn mehr aus dem Ganzen zu ziehen. Die Russen sind aber gezwungen, ihr Öl zu verkaufen, damit ihre Ölquellen nicht versiegen. Also sie müssen
es auch in irgendeiner Form loswerden. Sie können natürlich teilweise jetzt selber diese Versicherung bereitstellen oder zumindest versuchen, das bereitzustellen, aber das wird Ihnen auch nur zu einem gewissen Teil gelingen.
Davon abgesehen kriegen sie halt auch gar nicht den Zugriff auf alle Schiffe dadurch. Also es ist sozusagen einfach so, dass ein großer Teil der Schiffe, die sie benötigen, nicht in ihrem Besitz ist und auch nicht von irgendjemandem versichert werden kann.
Generell hatten wir dieses Thema Banken vs. Tanks schon von Anfang an. Und jetzt kann man erst einmal feststellen, die Banken haben wahrscheinlich jetzt nicht allzu viel russisches,
ukrainisches, von Russland besetztes Territorium befreit, aber sie haben sicherlich ihren Beitrag geleistet.
Aber die russische Wirtschaft ist nicht kollabiert bisher.
Aber es geht an Substanz und Rücklagen. Also ich habe Zahlen gehört, dass zwar noch Rücklagen auch da sind,
aber dass jetzt gerade die Russen halt diverse Rücklagefonds und Versicherungsfonds und so,
die sie für schlechte Zeiten angelegt haben, jetzt anbrechen und dass sie wahrscheinlich
für 2023 noch genug Geld haben werden, aber dass sie Ende des Jahres ernsthaft das Geld ausgehen könnte. Das haben wir natürlich jetzt mehrfach schon gehört, so erinnere ich mich, wo wir gesagt
haben, na ja, im Sommer oder so drei Monate.
Aber was tatsächlich passiert ist, ist, dass die Russen sich angepasst haben, sich auch.
In ihrer militärischen Strategie angepasst haben, jetzt wohl auch angefangen, ihre Rüstungsproduktion.
Tatsächlich anzukurbeln, indem sie dort sehr viel Druck machen und dem jetzt hohe Priorität,
einräumen und damit auch gewisse Erfolge erzielen, was die Rüstungsproduktion angeht,
natürlich aber auch zu Kosten vieler anderer Wirtschaftsbereiche, sodass das halt für.
Die Russen wahrscheinlich irgendwann auch anfängt, deutlich unangenehmer zu werden,
was die Versorgungslage angeht. Aber da kann man auch sagen, derzeit sieht es nicht so aus.
Dass größere Versorgungsengpässe, was die russische Zivilbevölkerung angeht, bestehen.
Da geht es den Ukrainern natürlich ganz ganz anders, deutlich schlechter jetzt, was die
Bevölkerung angeht, Wirtschaft angeht als Russland.
Und ja, so stellt sich so ein bisschen die Situation da.
Die Russen haben natürlich riesige Probleme und das Militär steht nicht gut da gerade.
Und es ist halt auch unklar, wie viel Kräfte jetzt Russland tatsächlich generieren kann und von welcher Qualität.
Also man geht jetzt ja davon aus, dass 300.000 plus mobilisiert wurden, von denen ungefähr die Hälfte bereits an der Front angekommen ist,
und geholfen hat, so ein bisschen auch die Situation zu stabilisieren, allerdings unter sehr, sehr hohen Verlusten.
Die anderen 150.000 werden noch ausgebildet und man kann davon ausgehen.
Dass die nächsten 150.000 ein bisschen besser ausgebildet und vorbereitet in.
In den nächsten Monaten auch als neue Einheiten an die Front kommen werden.
Gleichzeitig hat Russland natürlich hohe Verluste. Im Schnitt 700, 800 Tote wohl und wahrscheinlich 2000 Ausfälle insgesamt pro Tag.
Was heißt, wenn man das hochrechnet, dann sagen wir mal, grob 50.000 Truppen pro Monat fallen weg. Das heißt, die 300.000 reichen dann auch nur für sechs Monate, um letztlich dann nicht mehr zur Verfügung zu stehen.
Aber nichtsdestotrotz haben die Russen es geschafft.
Also noch bis März sozusagen.
Mit Hilfe von 150.000 Leuten die Situation zu stabilisieren,
was natürlich gewaltige Zahlen ist, wenn man davon ausgeht,
dass sie mit 200.000 überhaupt angefangen haben und jetzt nochmal 150.000 an die Front werfen mussten, um überhaupt die Ukraine aufhalten zu können.
Reden wir mal ein bisschen darüber, wie es jetzt weitergehen kann. Also, haben wir eingangs schon geschildert. Es hat sich jetzt erstmal sozusagen das Lagebild etwas stabilisiert. Es gibt diese Fortschritte.
Von Russland bei hohen Verlusten, aber die Russen gehen es halt offensichtlich einfach an mit irgendwie.
Egal, wir holen die Leute einfach irgendwo her, wir schicken die dahin und wir schicken so lange die Leute an die Front und lassen die da solange alles anlaufen, bis es irgendwelche Ergebnisse erzielt. Das ist
natürlich eine total zynische Grundhaltung, aber so ist nun mal der Krieg, den die Russen dort entfachen, während die Ukraine halt in irgendeiner Form versuchen, möglichst schonend mit ihrem Personal umzugehen, aber das geht,
halt auch nur so weit, wie es eben in so einem Krieg geht. Und jetzt droht natürlich, dass sich in diesem stabilisierenden Moment, sich in irgendeiner Formen beide Parteien neu aufstellen. Also drohen sich sozusagen gegenseitig. Und man kann durchaus.
Davon ausgehen, dass im Frühjahr irgendwelche neuen Aktivitäten geplant sind und zwar von beiden Seiten. Was genau, wissen wir nicht. Es ist offensichtlich, dass die Russen durchaus damit rechnen, dass die Ukraine versuchen wird, in der Mitte sozusagen das Kriegsgebiet zu durchschneiden.
Also speziell in einem bisher vom Krieg nicht unbedingt verschonten, aber zumindest nicht zu so einem Kernpunkt gewachsenen Bereich um Saporitia herum, dass man dort vorstößt,
um zu solchen entscheidenden Städten zu kommen wie Melitopol, womit man halt wirklich auf der Ost-West-Linie das Kriegsgebiet gekappt hätte. Aber die Verstärkungen, die dort stattgefunden
haben sind halt auch offensichtlich von russischer Seite. Was inwiefern es eben reichen wird, muss man sehen. Insofern ist es halt schade, dass diese ganze,
Panzerentscheidung so spät kam und es ist eigentlich auch noch schade, dass.
Auch im Bereich der Langstreckenraketen so wenig passiert ist. Das verstehe ich eigentlich auch genauso wenig und dort scheint auch so ein bisschen der politische
Druck abgenommen zu haben. Es gibt zwar jetzt diese Ankündigung, diese, wie hießen die noch gleich GLSDB Raketen Munitionen zu schicken. GLSDB Ground Launched Small Diameter Bomb,
das ist im Prinzip so eine Art Modifikation von existierender Munition, die man eben mit diesen High-Mass GLMRS Launcher Systemen verwenden kann, die halt die Reichweite erhöhen. Also kurz.
Gesagt wird da der Munition so Flügel verliehen, das heißt sie werden nicht nur abgeschossen, sondern die schweben dann auch noch mal GPS orientiert weiter. Das erhöht die Reichweite auf
150 Kilometer einerseits, aber sorgt auch noch für eine höhere Präzision oder zumindest für eine gleichbleibende Präzision bei Heimars. Das heißt man kann Objekte dann auch mit relativ wenig Munitionsaufwand auch noch sehr weit treffen. Das wäre auf jeden Fall sehr wünschenswert,
dass sich hier was tut, um einfach auch die Versorgungslinien der Russen weiter.
Abzuschneiden. Weil das ist natürlich nach wie vor der Nachteil, den Russland hat. Sie müssen halt einfach immer noch alles von weit weg her schaffen und das in großen Mengen. Und wenn es in irgendeiner Form gelingt, das abzuschneiden, Nein, dann ist gut.
Ja, wo wir noch nicht darüber geredet hatten, war, dass jetzt Sergei Zorovikhin, General Amageddon, der vor vier Monaten den Oberbefehl über die russischen Truppen übernommen.
Hat und es richten sollte, jetzt abgelöst wurde, was dann vielfach auch kommentiert wurde mit ja kaum haben sie mal jemanden der ein bisschen fähig ist so muss der auch gehen
und man muss sagen dass so wie kien es immerhin hinbekommen hat seine die russischen truppen,
größtenteils unbeschadet aus Kerson abzuziehen. Also das war wohl eine allgemein erfolgreiche,
recht komplexe Operation und es damit geschafft hat, dann auch mit den Truppen entsprechend den Rest der Front zu stabilisieren und insgesamt also, wie man sagen, jetzt keine allzu schlechte
Bilanz und der ist aber jetzt durch Valery Gerasimov.
Gelöst worden, der es jetzt lösen soll, dem Generalstabschef der Streitkräfte, der allerdings auch den desaströsen Invasionsplan verfasst hat, der nicht so richtig gelaufen
ist. Insofern besteht Hoffnung für die Ukraine, dass sie jetzt einen halbwegs fähigen Oberbefehlshaber.
Abgelöst haben durch ein potenziell eher weniger fähiges oder unfähiges General.
Der Grund dafür könnte wahrscheinlich sein, weiß es nicht genau, aber dass er sich einfach
zu viel Rücksicht auf seine Truppen genommen hat. also nicht bereit war, jetzt Truppen sinnlos abschlachten zu lassen oder umgekehrt sagen,
vielleicht nicht mit der nötigen Härte dann doch gegenüber den eigenen Leuten dann reingegangen ist.
Und deswegen hat dann Gerasimov als Erstes angefangen, wenn wir jetzt für Disziplin und Ordnung sorgen,
also striktes Alkohol- und Drogenverbot und keine Handys oder Tablets mehr am Arbeitsplatz.
Sag ich mal, für die Soldaten. Und alle müssen sich die Bärte abrasieren lassen.
Das hat natürlich gerade dann wieder bei bestimmten Ethnien für etwas Verstöbung gesorgt.
Natürlich insbesondere so die Kadirov-Truppe und so weiter.
Und es wurde dann auch gemunkelt, ob der Grund dafür vielleicht sei, damit halt die Gasmasken besser anliegen, weil die Russen den Einsatz von Chemiewaffen möglicherweise planen.
Aber ja, ich vermute mal, er versucht einfach nur vor allem, irgendwie Disziplinen umzusetzen.
Aber ob das funktioniert, da sind, glaube ich, Zweifel angebracht,
so dass das einfach so klappen wird.
Aber man wird sehen.
Auf jeden Fall, die Russen passen sich an, haben sich angepasst,
ändern auch ihre Taktik. Und so wird es wahrscheinlich weitergehen, dass man sich neue Dinge ausprobiert
und der Gegner sich dann jeweils darauf anpasst.
Wobei das Telefon- und Handyverbot, wenn es befolgt werden würde,
auch bedeuten würde, dass die Russen dann keine privaten, also keine zivilen Drohnen,
mehr benutzen dürften. So für die Aufklärung und das, also keine Ahnung, wie sie das zusammen,
bringen, ob es dann Ausnahmen gibt oder spezielle zugelassene Militär-Handys oder ich weiß
es nicht, wie Sie das handhaben werden oder die Leute an der Front einfach sagen.
Fuck it, was interessiert mich das? Ich habe hier die Drohne und wir werden
deswegen jetzt nicht aufhören unsere Drohnen zu benutzen. Und sind wohl derzeit,
gehört so eine Zahl, aktuell jeden Zeitpunkt ungefähr 4000 Drohnen unterwegs
an der Front, die gerade in der Luft sind, von beiden Seiten zusammen.
Die Drohnen haben wirklich übernommen. Okay, lass uns mal wieder ein bisschen Fokus finden und vielleicht auch langsam mal so zum Ende kommen. Die Frage, die so ein bisschen im Raum steht, ist natürlich, wie geht es weiter?
Und wo sind sozusagen jetzt noch Bedrohungspotenziale? Ich denke, so unsere Vorhersagekräfte versagen hier an der Stelle, weil es einfach so viele Unbekannte gibt, die man aus unserer Sesselsofa-Position schwer einschätzen kann.
Vielleicht noch eine Sache, die ich ansprechen wollte, weil die ja immer wieder in der Debatte ist, durch auch keine gute Antwort habe, aber das wollte ich noch mal einbringen, ist natürlich die Frage, inwiefern spielt Weißrussland jetzt noch eine Rolle?
Also es ist offensichtlich, dass Putin versucht, Weißrussland so aktiv mit einzubringen, wie es nur irgendwie geht, aber es macht ganz den Eindruck, als ob bisher zumindest.
Lukaschenko verhindert hat oder verhindern wollte, dass Weißrussland selbst mit seiner
Armee in diesen Krieg eintrifft. Ich meine, wir haben über diesen Aspekt so noch gar nicht gesprochen.
Vielleicht haben wir es mal angesprochen kurz, aber es gab ja so verschiedene Vermutungen, unter anderem, dass es halt nochmal eine neue Offensive auf Kiew geben könnte.
Also die besten Experteneinschätzungen, die ich dazu gehört habe, ist, dass zum einen derzeit und auch in den nächsten Monaten oder in diesem Jahr zumindest oder bis Ende des Jahres Weißrussland einfach logistisch vom Material her, von den Truppen her überhaupt nicht in der Lage ist.
Also sie sind noch nicht fertig oder noch nicht vorbereitet, um irgendwas zu tun, aber sie bauen halt Truppen auf. Das heißt, sie könnten irgendwann an den Punkt kommen, aber wahrscheinlich nicht dieses Jahr.
Aber gleichzeitig bauen auch die Russen ihre Truppen dort wieder aus.
Und sorgen natürlich einmal dadurch dafür, dass die Ukrainer auch im Norden Truppen stationiert halten müssen,
die sie nicht an der Front einsetzen können. Und man geht auch nicht davon aus, dass sie irgendwie erfolgreich sein könnten.
Bei und in einem zweiten Anlauf Kiew erobern. Also das haben sie beim ersten Anlauf, wo sie viel besser vorbereitet waren
oder in viel besserer Verfassung waren, ja nicht geschafft.
Und jetzt würden sie es erst recht nicht schaffen. Aber es würde natürlich trotzdem einfach eine zweite Front zu eröffnen.
Könnte halt zu irgendeinem Zeitpunkt durchaus Sinn machen,
aber wohl nicht anytime soon. Das war wohl die Einschätzung von Experten. Sie können noch nicht.
Ja gut, also wofür Weißrussland auf jeden Fall genutzt wird, also was passiert ist, es gibt sehr viel hin und her von Truppen und von Gerät.
Mal gehen Panzer rein nach Weißrussland, mal gehen Panzer wieder raus zur Front.
Das macht da so ein bisschen so den Eindruck, als ob Weißrussland von Russland vor allem verwendet wird für Training, Ausbildung von Soldaten, gegebenenfalls auch Reparatur von Gerät.
Also das sind einfach die Produktionskapazitäten des Landes, die dort existieren in irgendeiner Form mit Nutzen und natürlich auch die Ausbildungskapazitäten. Ein Angriff vom.
Norden her ist natürlich insofern etwas unwahrscheinlich, weil A würde er stattfinden, er würde jetzt noch sehr viel aktiver beobachtet werden, sodass die Ukraine sich darauf einstellen
kann. Davon abgesehen sind natürlich auch ganz andere Befestigungen vorgenommen worden an der
Grenze, also die Ukraine zieht an der Grenze zu Weißrussland, wie auch zu Russland an vielen Stellen einfach ganz andere Fortifications her. Also da werden Gräben gezogen, da werden entsprechende, weiß ich nicht, Minenfelder springen fallen, keine Ahnung, Benachrichtigungen.
Also noch mal werden die da nicht so reintrudeln. Und gerade auch diese ganze Debatte, ob zum Beispiel weiter im Westen auch noch mal eine Kampfzone aufgemacht wird. Ich glaube, das kann man beerdigen, weil es ist so ein sumpfiges Gebiet und da sind erst mal so viele zig Kilometer Wald,
die durchfahren werden müssen, dass da würden einfach die Truppen, egal ob es russische oder weißrussische sind, stecken bleiben, bevor die überhaupt irgendwo erst mal hingekommen sind.
Ja, aber nichtsdestotrotz würde es halt Kräfte binden.
Es würde Kräfte bringen, aber es würde auch nichts bringen. Also die Kräfte wären dann halt auch da.
Eine andere Erwartung ist jetzt aber, dass die Russen stehen unter hohem politischen Druck, irgendetwas vorzuzeigen.
Also ein Unentschieden reicht nicht bei den Russen. Die müssen halt schon auf Sieg spielen und die haben halt auch nicht ewig Zeit.
Also zumindest so können sie nicht sagen, jetzt okay, wir warten mal noch ein, zwei Jahre mit unserer Offensive.
Sondern da geht man davon aus, dass die Russen wohl so bald wie möglich und irgendwann in den nächsten zwei bis drei Monaten,
sobald das Wetter zulässt, Ende Februar, März, bis dahin in die Offensive gehen werden.
Vielleicht auch nicht, vielleicht bleibt die auch aus, aber im Moment wird dem eine hohe
Wahrscheinlichkeit eingeräumt, dass die Russen jetzt nochmal richtig aufdrehen werden.
Spätestens wenn diese 150.000 Mann ausgebildet sind und zur Verfügung stehen,
dass sie dann mit neuen frischen Truppen irgendwo versuchen werden, weiter Land zu gewinnen und wahrscheinlich den, ja.
Mit Luhansk und Donetsk einfach da komplett Land zu gewinnen.
Um dann vielleicht zu Verhandlungen zu kommen,
Westen zu demoralisieren, wie auch immer.
Also wahrscheinlich.
Als erstes eine russische Offensive, wobei die Ukrainer natürlich auch mal das Gefühl hat, wahrscheinlich schon seit längerem jetzt mit den Füßen scharren und gucken und eigentlich auch in die Offensive gehen wollen.
Die Amerikaner haben jetzt öffentlich sie aufgefordert, doch zu warten mit Offensive, bis jetzt das ganze neue Militärmaterial eingetroffen sind und die Truppen jetzt auch
besser ausgebildet sind an dem neuen Material.
Das heißt, es wird wahrscheinlich irgendwie so einen Sweetspot geben.
Auf der einen Seite werden die Russen stärker, auf der anderen Seite kommt natürlich jetzt
noch westliches Material und Ausbildung. Und eigentlich wollte man aber wahrscheinlich schon jetzt früher los schlagen.
Aber eine ganze Menge Truppen sind jetzt auch wohl gebunden an den Hotspots, wo man dann,
Verstärkung geschickt hat, also auch in der Gegend von Bachmut beispielsweise, weswegen das da so hart hergeht.
Von daher ist jetzt die Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass die Ukraine als erstes in die Offensive
gehen wird irgendwo eine größere ist jetzt gesunken und die Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass.
Die Russen die nächste Offensive größere vornehmen werden, ist jetzt gestiegen.
So und wahrscheinlich aber, wenn die russische Offensive dann stattfindet, geht man nicht
davon aus, dass sie allzu viel erreichen werden, weil dafür fehlt ihnen schlichtweg auch fehlen
die Kräfte. Und dann wäre der ideale Zeitpunkt für die ukrainische Offensive nach der russischen
Offensive ab April oder Mai, wenn dann auch das Material...
Da ist. Und das Problem aber ist jetzt, wenn es der Ukraine jetzt im Sommer nicht schafft, größere Erfolge zu erzielen, dann könnte langsam halt der russische Truppenaufbau.
Und Rüstungsproduktion und so weiter, könnte halt dann dazu führen, dass die Russen sich eben immer tiefer eingraben und auch immer stärker werden und dass der Aufwand, um dann
das Land zu befreien, einfach deutlich größer wird. Das heißt, im Moment räumt man der Ukraine eine recht hohe Chance eigentlich ein, tatsächlich
im Sommer was reißen zu können gegen die Russen. Aber wenn es das nicht wird, dann.
Rosten die Russen auf und dann sind wir bei den 2.000 oder 3.000 Kampfpanzern, die die
Ukraine dann braucht, von denen wir vorhin gesprochen haben. Wenn die Russen jetzt tatsächlich
sogar dann noch spektakuläre Erfolge haben oder es dann zu einem Waffenstillstand kommt.
Das ist dann die große Gefahr für 2024, dass die Russen dann einfach ein, zwei Jahre Auszeit.
Nehmen und dann eben nochmal wiederkommen.
Und dann während im Westen alle froh sind, Waffenstillstand, endlich ist dieser Horror
zu Ende und sich die Aufmerksamkeit so ein bisschen abwende, das ist so ein bisschen
das Gefahrensszenario, wohin es laufen könnte, wenn es dann zu einem Waffenstillstand kommt,
es keine Bewegung mehr gibt in dem Krieg. Bewegung heißt aber, dass eigentlich eine
Seite irgendwo drei-, fünfmal so viele Kräfte konzentrieren muss wie die andere Seite in dem
hinreichend großen Abschnitt und dann eben signifikant Bewegung da ist. Aber je länger
sich beide Seiten dann eingraben, umso weniger Bewegung wird es geben und wenn es keine Bewegung
mehr gibt, wird man irgendwann wahrscheinlich auch zu Waffenstillständen kommen und ja,
das ist dann, wenn die Gefahr zunimmt, dass dann auch wir irgendwann involviert sind oder
in dem ja später dann sagen die wenn die russen dann noch mal wieder kommen wir mit nato truppen.
Ran, ran müssten selber. Aber das ist.
Weil es keine Option ist, die Ukraine den Russen zu überlassen. Und wenn sie es aus eigener Kraft nicht schaffen, dann brauchen sie halt andere Kräfte.
Und nicht nur die Ukraine, sondern man kann ihnen halt gar nichts überlassen in dem Sinne. Das ist das Problem. Aber wenn man es ihnen auch nicht abnehmen kann, kann man sich halt auf den Kopf stellen.
Und deswegen, was glaube ich bei vielen Leuten noch nicht im Kopf angekommen ist, so richtig ist, dass je länger man wartet, jetzt die Ukraine mit dem Nötigen zu versorgen,
umso teurer kann das dann für uns im Nachgang werden.
Und in dem Zusammenhang gab es noch einmal einen interessanten Artikel.
Ganz vergessen hatte zu erwähnen von Garry Kasparov und Kudorovich, wo beide.
Dafür appellieren, keine Angst zu haben vor einem Ende von Putin.
Das ist halt so ein bisschen auch die russische Logik, warum wir Angreifer sind.
Das ist, weil das russische Regime halt nicht stabil ist, wenn es nicht alle paar Jahre
einen Krieg irgendwo führen und gewinnen kann. Denen braucht es halt, weil es sonst zu unpopulär wäre.
Und wenn wir also die Russen nicht alle paar Jahre irgendeinen Krieg gewinnen lassen,
dann stürzt die Regierung Putin und dann gibt es Chaos und dann gibt es Bürgerkrieg
und dann bringen die Russen sich alle gegenseitig um. Und das ist ja sowieso schon der Fall, weil in Wirklichkeit sind die Ukrainer ja eigentlich Russen.
Das heißt, wir haben jetzt gerade einen Bürgerkrieg schon angezettelt in Russland, wo jetzt die
ukrainischen russen gegen die russischen russen irgendwie sich gegenseitig töten.
Das ist jetzt alles in Anführungsstrichen, um mal deinen Tonfall ein bisschen so...
Ja, das ist alles genau. Das ist alles, so sagen wir jetzt, so ein bisschen die russische Logik gerade oder von Teilen der Russen. Und das Dilemma ist, wahrscheinlich würden die Russen jetzt nicht die ganze Welt unbedingt,
erobern wollen, aber so wie es aussieht, um sich jetzt sicher zu fühlen, würden sie halt wenigstens so, wie sagen wir, ja, noch Länder, in denen ungefähr 200 Millionen
Leute leben, kontrollieren müssen. Also das ist dann deren Einflusssphäre. Und dazu sind
halt diese 200 Millionen Leute einfach nicht bereit, sich sozusagen von den Russen irgendwie,
kolonisieren oder ja, vereinnahmen zu lassen. Deswegen ist das halt keine Option. Deswegen
ist es halt einfach illusorisch, dass das passieren wird.
Und das ist auch für die Frage, war der Westen jetzt schuld oder ist der Westen jetzt Kriegstreiber?
Naja, das, was die Russen brauchen oder das Regime Putin braucht, um stabil zu sein,
das kann man ihm schlicht und einfach nicht geben. Insofern war diese Konfrontation wahrscheinlich früher oder später unausweichlich, die wir da jetzt gerade haben.
Und jetzt wäre es, glaube ich, ganz gut, wenn man sie beschleunigt zu Ende bringt.
Und der Westen läuft sicherlich besser, als man das erwarten konnte.
Und der Westen hält auch zusammen und die Ukraine performt super.
Und die Russen sind schlechter, als man es geglaubt hat.
Also an sich laufen die Sachen gar nicht schlecht.
Aber die Gefahr ist nach wie vor da, halt von zu wenig zu spät und ja, dass irgendwann.
Dann im Westen das Interesse verloren geht und wer dann auf lange Sicht es dann eben
richtig teuer wird für uns.
Aber im Moment gibt es dafür keine Anzeichen, dass das passieren könnte.
Läuft es ja gut und wahrscheinlich ja.
Hoffentlich wird es entsprechend weiter positiv laufen. In der letzten Sendung haben wir gesagt, dass es möglicherweise eine Entscheidung in den nächsten Monaten geben könnte.
Diese Entscheidung ist ausgeblieben.
So und jetzt sieht es eher so aus, als wenn in den nächsten Monaten erstmal nicht allzu viel passiert, bis halt eine Seite jetzt mit der Offensive beginnt, aber das wird wohl noch auf sich warten lassen.
So sieht es im Moment aus.
Aber wenn wir das jetzt sagen, geht dann wahrscheinlich nächste Woche irgendwo eine große Offensive los.
Aber das kann halt immer passieren. Aber nichtsdestotrotz, hier sieht es rein aus Wetter und anderen Gründen sieht es gerade nicht so aus,
als wenn die Ukraine oder die Russen in Kürze eine Offensive beginnen würden.
Und dass es wahrscheinlich die Russen sein werden, die früher eine Offensive beginnen werden.
Aber wer weiß.
Naja, eine Offensive, also das ist ja auch so ein bisschen dieser Sichtpunkt, als würde es auf einmal so eine komplette Durchmobilisierung geben und an allen Stellen würde jetzt irgendwie was brennen. Das kann, glaube ich, auch Russland derzeit nur sehr selektiv machen, das probieren sie ja auch.
Es gibt immer wieder solche Versuche, in bestimmten Bereichen überall überfallartig in irgendeiner Form eine Änderung des Frontverlaufs zu erzwingen.
Das klappt dann mal besser, mal schlechter, aber wie schon geschildert, oft auch mit hohen Verlusten, aber dass es jetzt wirklich so eine koordinierte Aktion über die gesamte Frontlinie gibt.
Das halte ich halt nach wie vor für, naja, also vielleicht sollte man das Wort ausgeschlossen nicht benutzen, aber dafür sehr unwahrscheinlich. Aus verschiedensten Gründen.
Da ist halt einfach diese Versorgungslage, da ist das Bedrohungspotenzial der Ukrainer durch die Waffentechnik, die sie jetzt haben, sprich Heimat, relativ groß. Das heißt, schnelle Bewegungen auf der gesamten
Front ist kaum möglich. Zweites Problem ist, man muss ja auch sehen, wer kämpft denn da. Und es ist ja nicht so, dass es da nur die Russen gibt, sondern da gibt es halt irgendwie diese Wagner-Gruppen,
da sind auch diverse andere Gruppen, da gibt es diese sogenannten Rebellen da in Luhansk,
Netz, die auch nochmal separat organisiert sind. Das ist halt alles auch nicht aus einem Guss und oft hat man auch so den Eindruck, dass die im Wesentlichen mehr auch für die Gunst in der
russischen Innenpolitik gerade performen, als jetzt hier wirklich eine Kriegsagenda aktiv voranzutreiben. Insbesondere dieses Treiben von diesem Prigosin, dem also diverse Machtambitionen
in Russland nachgesagt werden, ist halt absurd. Da geht es wirklich darum, irgendwelche einzelnen Fortschritte erzielen zu können. Der lässt sich dann halt ablichten, weil er dann halt wirklich.
Auch an der Frontlinie ist. Als es da in Solle da abging, war er dann tatsächlich dort vor Ort, oder zumindest sah es halbwegs glaubhaft danach aus, dass er dort vor Ort war. Von daher habe ich auch nicht unbedingt so den Eindruck, dass Russland zu jedem Zeitpunkt so genau weiß, was es tut.
Also auch diese Vorstellung von, jetzt haben sie sich wieder gefangen und jetzt werden sie irgendwie mal total koordiniert und alle auf einem Ziel zu marschieren. Dafür hat sich dieser ganze Apparat auch für zu anfällig gezeigt in den letzten Monaten.
Deswegen wird der Ukraine nach wie vor gute Chancen eingeräumt. Aber generell sieht man schon, dass die Russen sich anpassen.
Und so historisch ist es wohl so, dass Russlands Armee im ersten Jahr eines Krieges wohl immer eine totale Shit-Show war. Aber dass sie sich halt schon irgendwann dann eingerüttelt
haben, weil irgendwann wird dann halt alles ein bisschen der Ernst der Lage klar und,
dann sortiert der Krieg halt so ein bisschen auch aus. Also insofern, ja, man weiß es
nicht. Auf der einen Seite geht Russland eben langsam das Geld aus, auf der anderen Seite weiß
man auch, dass das in Russland Leiden so ein bisschen auch offenbar für viele sinnstiftend.
Zu sein scheint und dass man daraus dann auch einen gewissen Stolz bezieht und insofern ja.
Ja, also noch tickt die Uhr so ein bisschen für die Ukraine so, aber langfristig geht.
Man davon aus, gibt man Russland genug Zeit und Ruhe, dann wird es sich halt auch allmählich.
Anpassen und organisieren und auf Krieg einstellen.
Aber wie weit die Zivilbevölkerung da bereit ist, dann mitzugehen.
Gesagt, das kann in die Richtung gehen oder kann auch nicht gehen. Also noch ist es halt
auch nur teurer geworden dort für die Russen, aber noch nicht irgendwie katastrophal, die.
Situation. Und wenn man das alles zusammennimmt, wie gesagt, wäre es halt deutlich günstiger
für alle, wenn die Ukraine im Sommer, das war vielleicht nicht das ganze besetzte Land befreit,
aber zumindest noch mal so deutliche Siege erzielt, dass in Russland dann der Glaube,
man könne da am Ende noch gewinnen, dann zunehmend verloren geht.
Das wäre so ein bisschen. Und da wird eben, da reicht ein Unentschieden wahrscheinlich alleine im Moment nicht aus.
Um das zu erreichen.
Und entschieden reicht nicht.
So, Pavel, wir wollen mal zum Ende kommen. Ich glaube, wir können uns hier noch fünfmal im Kreis drehen mit Voraussagen über das Ungewisse. Ganz gut, dass wir jetzt mal so ein Update gemacht haben, damit wir mal so ein bisschen wieder.
Den Ereignissen gerecht werden und ein bisschen zusammentragen, was aus unserer Perspektive passiert ist.
Damit wir dann vielleicht in den nächsten Wochen auch mal wieder ein bisschen aktiver auf kurzfristiges Geschehen eingehen können. Weil ich glaube so den Eindruck, da wird demnächst wieder was passieren, wo es noch mehr Gesprächsbedarf gibt.
Vielleicht noch ein paar Sätze zum Thema Atomkrieg. Erstens gab es aber, und ich wurde ja beim Fußball darauf angesprochen, was jetzt mit dem Atomkrieg ist.
Ah, stimmt ja. Vor Weihnachten gab es ja keinen.
Mit der Vorhersage habe ich ja recht behalten, so vor Weihnachten kein Atomkrieg, das ist ja eingetreten.
Tatsächlich ist es von Kreml-Seite aus eher ruhiger geworden.
Was Atomdrohungen angeht, hält man sich zurück.
Aber die kamen natürlich jetzt auch als Reaktion auf die Panzerlieferung.
Aber generell ist mein Eindruck, dass man da jetzt eine Nummer zurückgeschaltet hat.
Und jetzt zwar immer noch gerne Berlin bombardieren wollte wegen der Leopard-Panzer, aber meines
Wissens nicht mehr Atomar.
Ich frage mich, was die Amerikaner den Russen erzählt haben in dem Zusammenhang.
Das war's für heute.
Ja, es wird kolportiert. Ich kann es nicht bestätigen, aber das kommt durchaus aus, ja, das ist jetzt kein Gerede,
sondern das kommt sozusagen aus Akademia. Unter anderem der Justin Brank hat das auch erzählt.
Was gemutmaßt wird, ist, dass die Amerikaner den Putin klar gemacht haben, dass sie wissen,
wo er sich aufhält, jederzeit, und ihm gesagt haben, also wenn du irgendwie Atomwaffen einsetzt,
werden wir auch eine Atomwaffe einsetzen und zwar genau dort, wo du dich befindest.
Das war wohl so ein bisschen die Ansage der Amerikaner, also wenn du das machst,
dann killen wir dich mit einer Atomwaffe. Eigentlich keine dumme Drohung, so würde ich sagen.
Also scheint funktioniert zu haben. Oder ob das stimmt, oder die Chinesen haben auch gesagt,
Putin, hör mal auf mit dem ganzen Atomgeräte und den Indern, weil das ist schlecht fürs Geschäft,
und macht uns selber auch hibbelig. So, lass das mal sein.
Also im Moment sieht es nicht so aus und ja, also da müssten wahrscheinlich.
Also auch kein Atomkrieg nach Weihnachten.
Also laut russischer Atomdoktrin müssten die Ukrainer schon auf halbem Wege nach Moskau sein,
bevor man das wirklich ernsthaft in Erwägung ziehen würde.
Also selbst wenn sie irgendwie Rost auf einem Donnen oder so erobern oder so
so ein Stück da unten noch oder irgendwie ein Stück einmarschieren irgendwo auf russisches Gebiet, glaube ich nicht, dass das selbst das würde
wahrscheinlich nicht die Schwelle triggern. Aber am Ende kann man nichts mit Sicherheit sagen.
Gut, ich fühle mich auf jeden Fall erst mal sicher bis Ostern oder Pfingsten oder so. Okay, dann würde ich sagen, machen wir an dieser Stelle einen Schlussstrich und sagen vielen Dank fürs Zuhören und wir sehen mal zu, dass wir nicht wieder zwei Monate brauchen.
Bis zum nächsten Update und beobachten aber die Situation natürlich weiterhin für euch.